[Applause]
all right scum and Melanie
please welcome Kevin Smith and Mark
Bernardin fat man beyond
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernardi
[Applause]
dropped into the gig man how are you I'm
awesome
whatever
I mean I'm great it's all the show we
got for it kids we didn't really prepare
man uh thanks for being here we are at
the world famous scum and villainy
Cantina in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard put your [__] mitts
together so the folks at home know
you're real
[Applause]
oh they're real all right kids uh I
don't know what it's like in the rest of
the world but in California and
particularly in this neck of the woods
it is [__] hot supposed to be hot all
weekend long oh yeah like really bad
today it was up to like 90 in the valley
or something like that and I know that
because today I closed on my new home in
Studio City man
it's like we're neighbors we're gonna be
[__] close oh that's gonna be great
after what I've been in that house 21
years up in the Hollywood Hills uh we
bought a new house in Studio City and
today we got the keys and and me and my
wife for the fourth time in our lives
together uh moved into a new house we're
moving everything on like Thursday and
Friday but we got the keys today and we
took the dogs to the house and [__]
walked around the house and and
my wife was like should we do this I was
like it's [__] done like there's no
the should conversation should have
happened a while ago
um yeah man it's strange strange and
wonderful new adventure uh years and
years ago when we were making Jane Sal
and Bob Strike Back we lived in Toluca
Lake we rented a house there because I
was still living in New Jersey and back
then I was so like anti-california I'd
never lived in [__] Los Angeles all
the people are [__] fake and [__]
like that and so I was like Jersey
forever [__] Hollywood never and
after you know 11 months of living
anywhere you live in [__] Calcutta
for 11 months it becomes [__] home
and [__] so after 11 months of living in
Toluca Lake I was like you know what man
I could [__] do this I can get my
head around living here I remember I was
walking Harley in a stroller she was
still like really really young and there
was a house small house that was for
sale and I had like those pamphlets
sitting in a box in front of the house
and so I grabbed one and I was looking
at I was like you know I [__] maybe I
could live out here man everyone's they
may be fake nice but at least it's nice
like [__] I'll take that [__] and I
went back to Jennifer and I was like you
know like I think I could get my head
around living here finally I was like
there's this house for sale like around
the block at Toluca Lake and my wife is
like the valley oh God no only old
people live in the valley
well I'm old now man and so is she
because now we [__] live in the
valley so congratulations thank you very
much
um yeah it's the thing I discovered
today is y'all keep it hot over there
[__] man it's way hotter in the valley
than it is over here yeah but it's still
temperate it hasn't hit 115 yet in the
valley you're saying it's gonna get
worse [__] sorry I picked the wrong time
to move yeah and stop smoking weed yeah
that's true man what is today Monday or
Tuesday
Monday
today is and we are all of you people
like it's an easy question and it was 50
50 in this house today is 23 weeks that
I haven't smoked weed
um
don't applaud that life is colorless and
horrible
I'm so [__] sober I moved to the
valley for Christ's sakes
uh but yes more as it unfolds and
whatnot and once we're in and
everything's been moved over I'll have
you over of course I'll have you over
you [__] no but again I will be
broadcasting from there uh when we do
home shows and stuff if you've watched
fat man beyond from uh home recently you
keep seeing the background behind me get
more and more Spartan as things get
packed and moved away the house I'm
moving into the previous owner was a
real Gear Head so like it's a garage is
massive um and it was for like cars and
motorcycles but I'll never Park in there
so I'm gonna make that my office
particularly because it looks like Tony
Stark's garage
this is one of the selling points of the
house I walked in the house was
wonderful but I walked in the garage I
was this [__] looks like Tony Stark's
garage we'll take it so I'll be
broadcasting from that fans man
everybody give it up for JC
I I think your housewarming gift if
everybody wants to pitch in should be a
suit of Iron Man armor that you can put
in your garage I got enough space man
like the it's the the house that I live
in now
has giant walls that was one thing I
always had going forward High ceilings
the giant walls and we've got this uh
painting of Harley that Gottfried
helmine did like years ago when when we
first moved to California so the
portraits like 22 years old 21 22 years
old and it's big it's taller than me and
[__] way wider than me it's like
wider than us together with it's about
I want to say like eight by [__] six
or something like that giant panel
close-up of the kid's face that when you
look at it it looks like a giant blown
up photo but when you get close you
actually see the brush Strokes it's
pretty impressive and stuff so for years
it sat like in the foyer of the house
the moment you walk into the house it's
there to the right which was always
across from Harley's room and Harley
hated it her whole [__] life because
you know she'd open the door and she was
like Jesus Christ and it's staring there
and when she you know started bringing
friends home her friends would be like
oh she's like don't [__] look at it
and [__] like that
and so we torture all the time we're
like when we die it's yours and she's
like I'm gonna burn it I was like
[__] no you won't it belongs in a
museum and [__] so [__] her we might
donate it to a museum but I the room the
house that we got that we don't have as
high ceilings as we'd currently do but
in [__] the Tony Stark's garage the
ceilings [__] massive so that's where
the thing's gonna go so it'll now her
giant portrait will hang like in my
office she came over yesterday to see
the house as well
yes I'm gonna get a robot that I can
talk to call him dummy and [__] like
that I call him Jason Muse
um
[Applause]
yeah man it's crazy it's crazy this is
the first time that me and Jennifer will
be living
alone in our entire relationship like
when we first got together Brian Johnson
lived with us Jason Muse lived with us
then Harley [__] lived with us
because they wouldn't let us put Harley
someplace else and [__]
um Harley came along with Jen's parents
Byron agale who've always [__] lived
with us and stuff so this house is the
first time we're like actually by
ourselves which means we'll probably get
divorced in three months or something
like that
uh but yeah man [__] weird big steps
growing up Mark at age 52. I look
forward to the texts like hey man uh
what are you doing
do you want to come over and play video
games no it's gonna be like hey man do
you want to live with me and my wife
it's weird being alone here
I mean we're it's not like a real
trouble it's just we're trying it out we
just need a third for Christ's sake
somebody in the house making noise while
we [__] uh
I guess that's what it comes down to
never really thought about that but
that's what I need man some background
noise
totally oh my God it's gonna be creepy
when we're [__] and all I can hear is
her
I'm gonna have some white noise I'm
gonna have to make some noise for the
first time because I'm a very quiet [__]
just get like a podcast going in the
other room like far away that's true I
hadn't thought about what a podcast will
sound like in that giant garage because
sound very echoey probably
um the internet's gonna love it yeah
yeah [__] internet man the internet
has been like attributing a bunch of
things I didn't say to me for the last
like two [__] weeks and I keep
reading articles about like Kevin Smith
there's an article going around where
they were like Michael uslin Uh debunks
Kevin Smith's lie about Batman Beyond
because I remember I said like uh his
son David at the premiere was like Dad
you know I was waiting to find out the
news because he said like [__] if
flash does the business that the Batman
did they're talking about doing Batman
Beyond so I literally reiterated that
here same way as I'm doing right now and
then there was a bunch of Articles where
I guess Michael luzman was like I didn't
say that and so a bunch of people like
Kevin's been a [__] liar I was like
well then David uslin is a [__] liar
because his kid literally told me that
so on this show I'm not saying [__]
although I just did so [__] gives
them a chance to run that article over
again it's a cruel game my friend it
really is how are you what have you been
up to I've been walking the [__]
picket line man we're still on strike
still happening
Union power
[Applause]
fight the power my friend it could be
Union's power sounds like any second now
yeah last one was last week or a week
and a half ago
uh the nanny was out there she's the
head of the of sag Fran Drescher and
she's like wow but uh she was saying
like oh shit's going well and we're
probably gonna settle or what we're
talks are going well but now this week
the word is that like sag has been
making blank signs yeah they're getting
ready to join the fight propaganda
begins and all the images of a bunch of
very attractive actors stapling signs
together uh yeah that's the thing that
sag will have over the Writers Guild man
The Writer's Guild strike looks like us
yeah [__] and people could drive past
that [__] and whatnot but the SAG strike
is gonna look like [__] Jennifer
Lawrence
[__] Ryan Gosling and [__] like that
like I was out there today and we were
all like well this is the last week we
will be the most attractive people yes
to say the [__] at least
um speaking of Ryan Gosling we'll go
back to the strike but have you seen the
[__] Barbie trailer I mean the
trailer but not just that but there's a
new [__] like clip out where you know
he's uh he talks about like he's like my
job I'm not really a lifeguard my job is
just Beach
it's [__] he is [__] hysterical
and I saw some early reactions to Barbie
I guess they had a Premiere yet another
thing that we weren't invited to and
whatnot I mean I get it but also I don't
know man I if I was at [__] any
Studio I would invite me to everything
because like I [__] love everything
and [__] I understand not inviting you
oh I should not be invited tomorrow
but me I'm always like oh my God it's
the best thing ever oh my God that's the
best thing ever but we didn't get
invited this [__] thing either but a
bunch of early reactions from it people
are going like Ryan Gosling will
probably get an Oscar nomination for
playing [__] Ken [__]
and I'm here for it I ain't fighting it
at all I think he's funny man whatever
he's on SNL he's a legit funny [__]
dude motherfucker's been acting since he
was like [__] sperm man because he
was he was on the Mickey Mouse
get out of here the most entertaining
sperm in the bunch but he has been
[__] acting for for like a dog's age
at this point man so I'm not surprised
that he steals the [__] show in any
event see that clip online I'll show you
after the show it's [__] I mean he
might be good but comedians never win
Oscars
almost
is that right Kevin Kline is one of
maybe three people who's one definitely
the most recent person who won an Oscar
for a performance in a comedy and I
don't know that anybody considers Kevin
Klein a comedian right but it was A Fish
Called Wanda so like I get it but even
still like it just it's it's
historically under recognized by The
Academy Mr Phoebe Cates yes isn't that
wild
Mr Fish odor from Bob's Burgers
is that right that's really that's the
boys that's what he does now like he
literally all he does is Voice work and
I think it's mostly Bob's Burgers really
and he just doesn't do on camera stuff
anymore what's that all about I think
it's because he wanted to raise his kids
and then just got used to it it's like
well [__] it
he did like a Rick Moranis where he's
just like you know what's more important
than this anything
[Laughter]
um all right back to the strikes so
what's it been like so so the the picket
lines have been I mean they continue to
be kind of wonderful I mean it's the
spirit is strong even if the bodies are
weak and it's getting [__] hot in the
valley and lots of studios in the valley
a lot of reunions that's all the entire
Bones crew showed up for one of the
pickets yeah I know right
um yeah it's it's that's how they've
kept the spirits up all these themed
pickets like today were sci-fi writers
at Universal and so I went out there
because I'm a nerd and it was like a
[__] hundred nerds walking back and
forth across CityWalk and people I work
with on Picard people who worked on
other stuff like you you created V
didn't you nice welcome aboard
um but it's always lovely to hey meet
people you worked with before meet
people you're fans of just find people
with common interests I mean that's so
much of making a living as a writer in
Hollywood is about finding your tribe
and finding people who who also want to
do what you do also are trying just as
hard to get it done that can be support
that can be feedback that can be just
[__] rallying buddies and that's very
much what the strike has been is people
connecting across all of those things
and writers are like solitary by Nature
so to be on a picket line with a hundred
other people who do the same thing and
like the same [__] is kind of great
for people who are historically
introverted and like caves to live in I
got to imagine too that like a bunch of
writers like being forced to be together
under these conditions will result in a
bunch of [__] shows like once
everybody goes back to work it's going
to be like pitchgasm because
all these [__] writers been like
imagine if what if yeah like that's
great but but what if this too yeah yeah
I think it's lots of people you know the
Casual networking of it all which is
like hey you're cool I'm cool I might
have a show in six months I remember you
from the picket line let's [__] have
lunch and see what's what I think lots
of that will start to happen lots of
ideas will be born and lots of [__]
rows will begin rowing in the same
direction again and that's amazing [__]
an eye man and if the actors show up we
can all take a week off and let them
because the cameras will be there
because [__] it it's that's true all the
news will show up together Weavers at
Fox yeah [__] you alien job bursting out
of my chat Studios
it'll be a lot to that the funnier than
you [__] get
I'm just gonna say
um that's right like Meryl Streep will
show up to a picket in New York yeah oh
is that right I think she's in New York
cat did they pick it in New York
is that going on they do but it's it's
smaller because there's not that many
production locations and so walking back
and forth around the HB offices is just
like walking in front of the sidewalk
you're not stopping anything from
happening You're just showing Force I
suppose I was gonna pick it in front of
my movie theater but then I was like
be the one guy everyone's like what are
you doing buddy I was like I'm [__]
striking they're like about what I'm
like oh I should get paid more to write
they're like but you know what I do for
a living [__] you
you make pretend [__]
um I was uh uh at the theater
um last was it last weekend we did uh
Bears driving the clerk's cartoon
marathon with Brian o'hollary came out
and Jeff Anderson and the clerks cartoon
we like did six episodes of like 21
years ago 20 maybe 22 years ago at this
point Jesus I'm old and uh they only
aired two and then [__] canceled the
show and then we put all six out on like
a DVD like a year later and stuff but
it's uh
I haven't you know I've seen it over
time from time to time but always like
by myself I watched this with we had a
sold out show like 230 [__] people
and I honestly felt like the funniest
person in the world man this show was so
[__] funny and I was like what
happened to me I used to be funny now I
make depressing movies like clerks three
and then I realized what it was like I
didn't you know everything I write and
direct I write and direct the clerk's
cartoon was a group effort it was kind
of like the Masters Universe which thank
God there were a few writers because I
could spread the blame around and [__]
like that
um but the clerk's cartoon was like me
Dave Mandel who well me Scott Mosher
Dave Mandel Dave Mandel is inarguably
one of the funniest [__] people in
the business and [__]
um uh who else uh Steve lookner Brian
Kelly who went on to write for The
Simpsons for like a million years and
[__] and the guy who never gets enough
credit Paul deeney co-creator of Harley
Quinn
not my Harley Quinn the [__] cartoon
character and [__] he didn't live with
us back in the day
um but he he was the guy that came up
with the idea like you know because he
knew me and he knew Dave and [__] he was
like you guys are doing the clerks
cartoon they're like yeah he goes you
know what you should do as a second
episode a clip show
which for those that don't remember like
clip shows on TV shows were well for
those that don't remember a TV show was
they used to like you know during a
season they would always do a clip show
where it was like kind of made up of 85
clips of old episodes and they just shot
some wrap around material and stuff
right it's like oh Archie Bunker's in
the hospital
yeah and and people be hovering over the
bed and they'd be like remember that yes
Archie [__] excellent pull uh but one
that made me feel appropriately old
Archie [__] bunker that's you
couldn't have went for Urkel or some
such [__]
uh but yes he was like you should do a
clip show so the second episode was them
reminiscing about episodes we never did
instead which I think they are ABC aired
first nice which made no [__] sense
whatsoever that's also the reason they
did clip shows is because they were
cheap because they didn't have to shoot
anything new it was one set one actor a
couple actors whatever right so you got
to shave the entire other four or five
days of production and put that money
back in your pocket by just re-running
old [__] but you had to animate for
fresh all of the stuff in your Clips
yeah that defeated the purpose but it's
amazing I love that it was a good idea
man it was a good idea after that we did
well we had showed uh you know Indiana
Jones had opened the day before and we
did a watch with Kev or I watched that
with people and then we did Clerk's
cartoon Marathon the day after that we
did the Blues Brothers and we had
[__] 160 people show up for the Blues
Brothers a movie you could literally
watch at home so after that I said to to
Ernie a smart Castle keeper Ernie
O'Donnell I was like I'm going to be
there all summer because that's where
we're going to be shooting the 4 30
movie if if sag strikes
I think we still get to shoot because
we're a low budget movie at least that's
what I've been told and [__] although
that's when the strike will show up in
New Jersey I'm sure
but uh don't tell anybody
um but uh when I was uh when I was there
I was like we got to start showing old
[__] like [__] since I'm gonna be
there all summer let's show old stuff so
we show a series of movies called like
the movies that made me and so
um The Blues Brothers was one of them so
now we've got coming up for the movies
that made me we're doing Ghostbusters
we're doing uh midnight run
um we're doing [__] I forget there's a
few it's at smodcastlecinemas.com but
then
um I came up with oh let's do Eddie
Murphy Mondays
and so every Monday night isn't Eddie
Murphy yes it's a [__] Eddie Murphy
movie so we're showing like uh uh um
Beverly Hills Cop [__] uh Coming to
America coming to America trading places
that will be that's not on the first
month but it will be there because I
love the [__] call me when you do
both finger and Bowfinger will that's
going to be in the fall because that's a
thinking person's building
but um we just you know we thankfully
Eddie Murphy made most of his movies
with universal uh with Paramount rather
and Paramount is very good about letting
you show old movies God thank God he
didn't make a bunch of movies with
Disney because then we wouldn't have
access to him so you're not going to
play The Haunted Mansion starring Eddie
Murphy no no
there was never a danger of that but I
would have loved to have shown Mulan you
know that's what led to him doing Shrek
remember like he did Mulan and then
katzenberg left Disney and he [__]
went created DreamWorks he's like come
be a donkey and then Eddie Murphy got
like [__] insanely rich and like
Kevin Klein was like I don't need to act
anymore either and [__] so yeah man
[__] if all throughout August if
you're on the East Coast uh come watch
old ass movies with me on Sunday uh was
it Saturdays no Sunday is the movies
that made me series and then Monday is
uh the Eddie Murphy Mondays and stuff
our show is sold out the [__] fat man
beyond we're doing August 25th we put up
a show for yes thank you we put up a
show that person bought tickets we uh we
put up a Tusk screening with Justin long
and that is going on uh was August 12th
and I think there's like five tickets
left for that so the theater's been
[__] rocking it man it's been a good
time
and then last weekend
just two days ago I went to Knoxville
for a fanboy Expo which was fun I was
there with Jason Muse and taking
pictures and signing [__] and whatnot
Joey Adams was there as well so it was a
little like Chasing Amy reunion
um and the next con that I got is geeked
Con in August I think it's like August
19th and that's in Shreveport Louisiana
don't you have one in like 10 days
oh God that's right
good point there's another Con coming up
little known you've probably never heard
of it
that's right we've got the San Diego
Comic-Con coming up and just like last
year uh we took over the Tin Roof Inn in
San Diego and turned it into a movie's
pop-up and that's where we're doing
shows and we put up our shows for sale
to that Kevin Smith club members and
they sold it out so before tickets could
even go on sale to the general public uh
Jane Sal and Bob get old fat man beyond
and Hollywood Babylon like sold out
instantly so yes thank you
so
um you could still obviously you get
food at movies and [__] and that's the
home base for us that's where I'm gonna
be most of the time I have a panel uh
for Masters of the Universe on Thursday
uh with
um uh Chris Woods going to be on the
panel Melissa Benoist
um I forget who else but Tiffany Smith
Tiffany Smith's going to be there as
well the other the only Smith worth a
[__] and uh
and then after that I'm monitoring the
panel for Sav Rogers movie Chasing
Chasing Amy the documentary which is
like been
taken plot it's like crazy at its
Festival run people really love the
flick but that's the only real
interaction that I've got with the con a
lot of people are you doing Hall h this
year but I didn't really have anything
to talk about at Hall h and so I was
like I before everyone else canceled on
Comic-Con because like [__] Marvel's
not going I guess James Gunn said DC's
not going
um Netflix ain't going a bunch of
Studios aren't going because everyone
thinks the strike's gonna happen and
they can't promote anything anyway but
even before that months ago I was like I
don't think I'm gonna do a whole H panel
because last year like you know we had
clerks three coming and [__] I had [__]
to talk about what am I gonna do go up
on holiday should be like I bought a
house in the valley you know
so uh so I don't even have a Hall age
show so the place to see us will be at
the Tin Roof Inn and stuff and we're
doing photos that's the only thing I
think that's left that people could buy
is like you can take pictures with me
and Mark me and Ralph me and Jason and
stuff like that but the events have sold
out you're right I completely forgot San
Diego Comic Cons coming up what is it
going to be like it looks it's so weird
there'll be no news coming out of San
Diego Comic-Con it'll be a proper comic
book convention yeah good point
this is the year of comic books it very
much is uh
we're uh we're screening Splinter like
Comic-Con [__] when where Thursday
Thursday night at 7 30 in room 10.
anybody wants to roll through free of
charge we'll have some actors there
Tiffany we'll be there nice I think
Trisha Helfer might be in town
um six Moon Blood good is thinking about
coming in Yvette Nicole Brown might be
there Captain Shaw himself Todd
stashwick is going to be there
um moderated by David de smalton Dave's
doing your moderation yeah [__] hey
man so we'll show it we'll talk about it
we'll have a good time that's Thursday
night and then I got panels all day
Friday all day Dave dismalchen is your
moderator yeah
what the [__] man you didn't know if you
were going literally yeah you're like I
don't know if I'm gonna be there [__]
I'm making a movie [__] I don't know
I don't know I forgot Dave's a good get
if you want to come you can come yeah I
will all right it's Thursday right
Thursday 7 30. oh that's when I'm doing
Jay and selling Bob
yeah I'm preoccupied
um but yeah it'll be fun I'm doing
signings and the dark horse and a
Distillery which is a new comic book
publisher that I'm doing some work with
I got some fun ass panels to be honest
all about my Instagram if you want to
come down but but Splinter is the big
deal it's bringing that short to
Comic-Con feels good that's gonna be
it's like a home good for you man give
it up for Mark he made a thing
[Music]
because I don't know if you know this
Kev but heartbreak feels good in a place
like this
I'm sorry it's the blue milk man I was
gonna say [__]
um all right do we have a sponsor we
don't are you [__] me this is just
free balling in free tube in this show
nobody paid for us well then this show
is sponsored by uh secret stash press my
comic book label uh through Dark Horse
the first four issues of quick stops has
been uh collected into a hardcover is
there one here no
um and then the first four issues of
masquerade uh the book that I do with
Annie mcelfish and John springelmeyer
has been uh put into one of those Dark
Horse makes these beautiful [__]
hardcovers man I had them a few shows
back I think I showcased them and stuff
but I believe they're in comic book
stores this week if you're into comic
books and [__] good point man [__]
this year's con is going to be a
Comic-Con I know it hasn't been that
long walk the halls and not touch
strangers you can you can buy art from
people and not have to bid against them
with development Executives you can you
can skip Paul H you cannot walk in that
Hall period yeah wow skip the line
um all right so [__] no sponsor I
guess we should
just uh
what's your name
this Show sponsored by Jesse Campbell
do you have a problem with your dick
talk to Jesse Campbell
I mean that's really all sponsorship is
somebody gives you money and they you
say [__] about him so like I guess we
literally could have a bunch of people
like here's 10 bucks say my [__] name
yeah it's like it's like buying a cameo
but on the biggest possible stage
um all right with no sponsor we get to
dive right you know what [__] there
is a sponsor there is this here [__]
show is sponsored by the scum and
villainy cantina
okay since I'm the sponsor can I ask a
question [__] yeah man you do anything
you want as the sponsor so before the
show Mark was like I've been coming to
the bar for six years
and I've never had a blue milk and he's
on number two how is it can you give a
blue Milk review
I mean I thought they smelled bad on the
outside
what's what's in a blue milk uh
pineapple juice rum
coconut
it's like a pina colada yeah no it's how
is it blue what's making it blue blue
curacao which is like a citrus liqueur
so is it vegan
uh maybe you have a sip well if it's
vegan I'll take it yeah there's no
animal products in it it's all fruit
I'll have a blue milk oh my gosh
let's go
that's how we treat the sponsors man I
eat blue too I use manscaped
so I [__] should drink a blue milk
we're sure it's vegan though no milk in
it there's no milk yeah there's no it's
all fruit it's called Blue milk but it's
a lie yes
the uh the soy milk
and that's vegan isn't it
there's no soy milk in the blue milk
that's green milk that's the titty milk
you sell a drink called titty milk it's
the the green milk oh my God look at the
straw glows like a lightsaber oh that's
a
it's not a straw yeah you need an actual
straw
you say I would have been like
oh this straw doesn't glow at all
right man we're gonna [__] tonight
reminds me when you were drinking the uh
Bud Light strawberry [__] yeah I got
real pandemic shows
um [__] that's pretty good
I haven't had weed in 23 weeks but I
might get [__] up tonight
[Applause]
that's very refreshing
it's a cool refreshing drink I'm gonna
start being honest real soon
you know what I really think about the
Flash
you know what man The Flash left my
movie theater in a [__] flash like it
was only its mod castle for nine days
and then Ernie Let It Go I was like why
he's like literally nobody was coming
um but I still like I I still enjoyed
that movie I watched it four times it's
the only movie I've seen like four times
in recent memory I mean they wish you'd
paid for it four times yeah
I did pay for it I had it at my movie
theater for nine days
um
but it was good times man still for me I
I previously mentioned probably to my
detriment that I shot the screen like I
look like the movie for uh the portion
of Michael Keaton as Batman and stuff
and I still watch it periodically when
I'm taking a [__] or something I'll sit
there
like Michael Keaton is Batman like it
was still one of my favorite things
that's happened very recently however
what is today
the 10th that [__] blue milk is
hitting hard [__]
it's a half these people didn't know if
it was Monday or Tuesday so you know
really uh today's the 10th in eight days
we can watch the flash on at home
yeah yeah it's like coming to home video
July 18th one of the fastest turnarounds
pun intended of a movie of major
theatrical release
that was [__] that window was brief
barely open yeah truly but I you know no
complaints here I'm gonna watch the [__]
out of it
are you going to keep your little
pirated copy for nostalgia
I might just because like it's like the
best part like him [__] uh throwing
batarangs and kicking ass and stuff oh
so [__] good
um so yeah I might I might keep that
I like it sounds so weird to say but I
think I'm already buzzed
I never I never [__] with alcohol so
like that really went someplace fast
why did I buy a house in the valley
give me three more blue milks quick
Jen I started drinking
quick don't sell the other house
um all right man should we get into it
well let's get into it uh we gotta we
got new we oh we got reviews yes we're
gonna talk about a TV show
um all right oh secret invasion oh [__]
I drank this too soon
[Applause]
I know too much truth is gonna spill out
uh all right yeah uh we watch secret
Invasion I watched two episodes Mark
watch three yeah uh and uh I didn't
watch the third not because I was like
[__] this show I just haven't caught up
with it yet but um is anybody else
watching secret invasion
how many people have have how many
people want to not watch secret Invasion
put your hands together real quick
how many people are not going to watch
secret invasion
wow that was an enthusiastic pass right
there uh for those at home watching or
for those who don't know Disney plus of
course is airing secret invasion which I
saw somebody online wrote an article
about how this is one of the first
Marvel shows that doesn't have a
character team name in the title or
something like that they were saying
that's the reason why the viewership is
so low because it's just like Marvel's
secret Invasion yeah nobody knows it's
not like Iron Man's and and the secret
Invasion or whatever right Falcon Winter
Soldier Ms Marvel Loki
Vision that had two [__] names in it
it really did uh this is just secret
Invasion so if you're not paying close
attention you know maybe you skip it
yeah they didn't even call it like Nick
Fury secret Invasion which would have
made sense because it's all about Nick
Fury yeah but also would have been like
dirty
and that might have made people [__]
watch the Sans and The Hourglass Nick
Fury is going to invade I've seen many a
story about how the debut episode was
one of the least watched Marvel shows on
Disney Plus in the subsequent episodes
of have not done much to help the cause
um it's not it's surprising to hear as
many people I guess not surprising
because we're a concentration of of of
nerds and Geeks in this room but it
seems like a lot of people are not
watching secret invasion I mean I and
it's hard to to put a finger on why
um because that that's marketing that
has nothing to do with quality it's how
did Marvel not mobilize the troops that
they usually managed to mobilize to
watch their stuff and and it's
another one of these you got this money
[Applause]
and it's hard I mean maybe it's because
you couldn't put Sam Jackson on a talk
show maybe it's because the The Writer's
Guild has made the no late night stuff
and you just do an online press and I I
don't know I can't put a finger on
because he's still Samuel [__]
Jackson so I was gonna say it's it's one
of the oldest Marvel Universe characters
in terms of all these movies and TV
shows he's been around since the end of
Iron Man for God's sakes and he is uh
according to IMDb the highest grossing
actor in the history of Hollywood he and
Harrison Ford flip-flopped back and
forth but he has been in the most high
grossing movies of any actor working I
guess that makes sense yeah I mean aside
from the Marvel [__] who's in like Pulp
Fiction which made a hundreds of Park
he's in three stores oh my God that's
right holy [__] he's he's [__] up
there if I ever tell you I must have
told you this the [__] Stan Lee Story
one day the late great Stanley was still
with us he told me he goes Uh Kevin I
read an article today about how I'm one
of the highest grossing actor in
Hollywood history and I was like how and
he goes because I'm in all the Marvel
movies doing cameos thank you and I was
like oh my God that's right like [__]
you're always cameo in the movies and
he's going yeah if you look at a graph
it's a bunch of successful movies and
Mall Rats
[Applause]
[Laughter]
to stand
[Applause]
I sucked the lightsaber again and it
didn't work
anyway so back to this [__] show
[Laughter]
uh if you haven't watched human Invasion
it is ostensibly about the skrulls which
if you maybe weren't paying attention to
Captain Marvel they were in Captain
Marvel a movie that made a billion
dollars it was it did he was they did
they did whatever
um and in the in the mid credit sequence
of Captain Marvel they revealed that
Nick Fury is on some spaceship uh sword
sword and saber
launching saber or whatever it is but
anyway that's where he was and so we
pick up now in secret Invasion and Nick
Fury's called back to Earth from his
astral area
um to hunt Scrolls I guess because
there's now a scroll terrorist named
gravic played by uh Kingsley Ben adir
who is he he was Malcolm X in one night
in Miami oh yeah he's a great actor
um and this the [__] cast of this
show is bananas like he's got Olivia
Coleman it's got Olivia Coleman it's got
Emilia Clark it's got Ben mendelsohn
it's got Kingsley benedir it's got
Samuel [__] Jackson
um and it's kind of a spy thing it's
kind of a paranoia thing it's kind of a
the scrolls are Among Us they've
infiltrated us to the highest of levels
and they're planning to do some bad [__]
and only Nick Fury can stop them and
Nick Fury mayor may not be up to the
task what it should be is Captain
America the Winter Soldier right because
that was their Espionage Thriller
at the heart of which was like [__]
Hydra has been infiltrated [__]
shield and and has been around for a
long time and stuff and that's what it
should be it's what it feels like it
wants to be and secret invasion is is
Loosely based as much of Marvel is on a
sort of big crossover rock that they did
in the comic books where they revealed
that many of the characters that you've
been reading for the last 10 years or
whatever had been replaced by Scrolls at
some point so the Tony Starkey was doing
Tony Stark [__] he then revealed that
the real Tony Stark is in a bunker
somewhere being held captive while the
Tony Stark who's been part of the
Avengers was a scroll the whole time and
it was that kind of all over the Marvel
Universe and that [__] was interesting
because you were playing with characters
which were already attached to who may
or may not have been then who may or may
not have been acting across purposes
but the show never gets to really play
with shape shifters of it all like
that's what's [__] cool and they do
open spoilers if anybody hasn't seen a
secret invasion
sorry
um but they open with with Martin
Freeman as agent Ross they do and he's
like in Terry getting some dude about
some [__] or whatever and then you
reveal that this Martin Freeman this
agent Ross
um has been a scroll is this are they
saying that he's always been a scroll
it's unclear when the kidnapping and
shape-shifting happened but at the very
least we're left to wander open-endedly
oh [__] if he's a squirrel who else is a
scroll which is the candy of this idea
except then they kind of don't do
anything with it and it becomes about
terrorists stealing dirty materials to
make bombs it's like okay well I
likes I mean that's kind of
Kyle Jordan is kind of
for your other terrorist movie we've
ever seen right but these guys can
shape-shift like why isn't it more fun
why aren't we doing more of that and the
answer is probably we hire these actors
to play these roles and we need to see
these actors also that's how you keep
the budget down right like uh at the end
of the day scroll makeup costs money the
transformation costs money and stuff but
you know if you're just like you could
say they're Scrolls but they look like
[__] famous actors who you're already
paying a lot of money to why would you
go through the process but that's what
kind of takes the fun out of it it's
like if you're like you know they got
their whole scroll community and [__]
where they're like this is where we're
free to be Scrolls but we still look
like people
you know seems like they're kind of
cheaping out on the idea of like let
them let a scroll be a scroll that's
what I felt in the first two episodes I
was like not enough Scrolls in this
[__] man yeah and like it's not even
like I can point to anything in the show
and be like that's executed poorly
because it shot very well shot very well
it shot on location overseas like again
you've got great actors doing great [__]
but there's just something at its core
that isn't quite as transgressive maybe
as you want it to be it doesn't take the
Liberties that you hoped it would take
and it just feels very conventional
and as a conventional spy thing then
you're like all right well then we're
going to be born identity right like
well no because Sam Jackson's 80 years
old and so he can't do Bourne Identity
[__] in real life yeah
really
I
I mean I guess that tracks like he was
in Good Fellas and he was already old
[Laughter]
I mean wow he's old in Jurassic Park
like he famously wouldn't run in the
Avengers because he's like I'm too old
to be running Joss Whedon so I'm not
running anywhere and Josh was like I
need you to kind of amble after this
helicopter with a rocket launcher it's
like [__] you man I told you I wouldn't
do it but I'll I'll [__] lean quickly
out of this door with this rocket
launcher
I'm I'm 52 Sam Jackson is 80 years old
74. sorry oh my God don't do that oh man
like that's that much better I mean six
years makes a difference
but no he's still old but no wow [__]
he looks good he was what
there you go yes the those five years
count
ing that's good
um that was nerdy that was as good as
Mark's joke that he was mad nobody
laughed at
so I've gotten over it I've gotten over
it although I look forward to the
internet saying that I chastised a room
full of people for not laughing
as long as they don't attribute some
[__] quote to you that you didn't say
no they'll attribute it to you yeah
truly [__] it hangs on you like herpes
Mike Mike
I don't mind telling you I'm pretty
drunk right now man I'm talking those
two drinks hit me real [__] hard
these you want my review
that's [__] good
there you go put it on the post yeah put
that on a poster my grandfather better
than secret Invasion he used to describe
things oh damn well I mean come on
that's that's not even a hot take for
God's sakes
I I'm liking this new Kevin Smith honest
yeah yeah
I mean when a season I say it's what I
mean
um yeah I I'm two episodes in and and uh
I'm more enthusiastic about it with uh
than my wife I've been watching it with
Jen and at the end she's like what do
you think I was like yeah I'm in and
she's like I'm out and she's been doing
other things instead she's been
listening to actual Espionage podcasts
while we watch the [__] show
um it's it's just I was wondering if it
was me like maybe I just got to a place
where I'm too old to [__] enjoy this
[__] the way I used to but I don't think
it's me because I [__] went crazy for
the Flash
so I don't you know I'm not saying
Marvel's lost it but like this this one
ain't grabbing me man I don't know what
it is and like you said it's incredibly
well made it's not like oh they [__]
dropped the ball or they they're not
spending the money right it's just not
it it feels like they don't know where
they're going in phase four or five
no and it also feels like
it's so much of a type of thing like if
you look at it you're like oh no no
that's 100 like born or like jealous
Tinker Taylor Soldier Spy or like Bridge
of spies or whatever it is like there's
enough things you can point to in the
world like I see where you're going for
except all of those things are better
and so you're just left with me like
okay I mean
I I get what you're trying to do but
you're just not hitting it and the the
bar is a little too high and it's a
little too noticeable that you're not
getting there
but it's not bad it's just kind of
man
yeah mid
oh God yeah that's the worst thing you
could say on the Internet is called
something mid and whatnot
but yeah yeah Pam oh hello thankfully
the chat has uh deemed it secret
midvision
oh
oh chat's brutal yeah that's tough but
not unfair
wow
um
what happens in episode three
uh I heard that can I spoilers in case
you haven't seen it [__] Amelia
Clarke gets Khaleesi gets killed uh she
does get shot it's unclear if she's dead
or not how [__] up was it that they
killed Maria Hill
[Music]
[Laughter]
I guess you and I were the only ones who
were like what the [__]
I have expected heard of them to be like
oh she's a squirrel too that's the
character who's been around since the
beginning of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and they're just very
unceremoniously let her get shot yeah
and and like I don't mind killing a
character like I get what it does for
you right like suddenly you as an
audience become invested you hope that
the character for whom that person meant
a lot to is either motivated right like
you expect Sam Jackson ah [__] it it's
time to roll hard and get my revenge
from Ms Hill it should motivate him and
it kind of does it
at all we met her mom at one point and
she was like make this mean something he
was like all right and then he didn't
[Music]
yeah it was just odd
it was very odd again they're also like
It spoilers again they seem to be
setting up the super Scrolls
right you know which probably saw that
in a trailer at one point he does the
stretchy thing right so like is he is
now the next wave of the scroll attack
front impersonating superheroes in which
case like all right I suppose maybe that
could be cool but
who am I going to care about that you're
gonna impersonator you good impersonate
Thor
oh that's the thing man they need to
bring some star power into it and [__] a
little bit yeah well they got you know
um roads man Roadie uh they got Don
Cheadle who they've been to that might
be or the internet seems to think he's a
scroll as well could be although he's a
skull who seems to have a very service
level uh understanding of race relations
in America
explained
well it says okay
it's just there's a lot of him like
there's this conversation between the
two of them and there's empty restaurant
I saw that yeah where they're talking
about like people with skin like us have
sacrificed a lot to get in the position
to tell people who don't look like us
what to do and where to go and then like
yeah but also it's about telling you
that you're fired say what is this
[__] conversation about
like suddenly we're in like a [__]
bus waiting room in 1968
to take some ride for the cause and
these two old black men are talking
about sacrifices and like where where
yeah that was a weird scene you know I
mean God bless Marvel every now and
again they try to like to like swing
into a thing about a thing sometimes it
works black panther one is very
intentionally about that it's very much
about being African and it's very much
about being African-American and the
hype in between the Black Panther one
for a second I thought the sequel was
called Black Panther one he did it you
guys w-o-n he won all the fights
um you know and so Ryan coogler was very
intentionally making comment and
commentary about the black experience
about Africa about responsibility and
blame and all of that [__] and it works
because also the movie's great
uh and then like Falcon Winter Soldier
kind of tries to tell you the price of
being a patriot and being black and it
gets there sometimes I mean all the
Isaiah Bradley stuff is really really
strong and then Anthony Mackey delivers
a 20-minute speech solving race in
America
I remember when that happened yeah
thanks bro you did it everything [__]
went it was good for the first time ever
in America yeah it turns out all lives
do matter in the Marvel Universe
yeah
except Emilia Clark listen the
internet's gonna come for me on that be
good good yeah I ain't drunk enough to
start saying black things
I'm like take it away Mark yeah
excuse me I speak Jive
um I ran out of blue milk
[Applause]
can somebody get a cow in here this is
as dangerous as Super Chat yeah [__]
and Super Chat nearly destroyed the show
it really did but [__] it if we keep on
playing you with blue milk super super
Invasion secret invasion
uh it's how many episodes anybody know
six three three so far so we're halfway
through
well maybe something wonderful will
happen in the next we're Living on a
Prayer thanks oh [__] yes
yeah look at those two empties
[__] this one's to you Ma
we're gonna have to call you an Uber
when this is done oh my God my wife's
gonna have to pick me up I'm like we're
watching secret Invasion episode three
I have this blue milk and then we got a
Grimace shake and then [__] got hurt
turned
we all live in the Valley now we could
carpool
it's true you live in the deep valley
I'm deep yeah although about the same
level deep as Mark yeah where are you
guys I'm not by like Woodland Hills I'm
West Valley he's like North Valley oddly
enough I live like two blocks from my
old weed store
which is so heartbreaking because now I
could walk to my weed store but like
what's the point it's like the
definition of ironic it is it's well
it's the Alanis Morissette definition of
ironic not the actual difference
you can just walk by and like put your
nose up on the window like look at the
weed like remember buddy I feel like
there is ah Caviar Gold
um
uh all right secret Invasion secret
midvasion as the internet as the church
is yeah
yeah
uh where do we go next uh we go to some
very limited news because it turns out
because we don't have anything else to
review trying to think if I watched
anything did you see anything else
here just gonna throw this comment Evan
Fowler in chat says not gonna lie I'm
curious to see where this goes dot dot
dot and then in parenthetical it says
Kevin and Mark my kiss tonight
[Laughter]
oh my God it'd be like [__]
it'd be like Kirk and Aurora kissing and
[__]
[Laughter]
this show was sponsored by gentle
homosexuality
sponsored by curiosity
Suburban curiosity yo if somebody's got
Fast and the Furious in their [__]
phone right now we could get them to
watch it
[Music]
it's true I've never seen anything fast
nor Furious episode one of fasting by
curious the podcast you've always won
lasted by curious
um yeah have I watched anything I've
been watching a lot I mean this is not
like a
recent review but I I finally started
watching Parks and Rec
what an amazing [__] show yes like
really fantastic Where Are You episode
uh 10 of season five wow okay yeah I'm
good yeah I'm like little Sebastian has
come and gone
but he keeps getting referenced all the
time
um Tammy it's Ron Swanson's Tammy has
happened like five times
yes but Tammy too definitely she's
[__] hysterical man
um yeah it's a [__] wonderful show I
know most people like we watched it a
decade ago bro I've been busy I was
making [__] I can't watch [__] Parks
and Rec I was making yoga hosers thank
you
[Music]
um but what a fantastic [__] show man
everyone firing also on all cylinders
and you know who's a huge fan of that
[__] show Kevin foggy yes because all
of those [__] wound up in a Marvel
thing and even what's her name [__]
um you know uh
[__] Janine Garofalo but not Janine
Garofalo
Aubrey Plaza thank you wow
I mean she kind of like the whole time
I'm like that's Gene Crawford I don't
like do you think Garofalo was like
skinny and Puerto Rican
um she uh she's just signed up for a
Marvel thing too did you know yeah I saw
that she's coming to the Marvel Universe
but yeah a lot of those [__] wound up
in the Marvel Universe man and I think
like Kevin foggy must be a fan
uh Parks and Rec is my new weekend fall
back view because on cable it's on like
every Saturday and Sunday for like five
hour blocks really on TBS and I'll just
drop in like what are we doing now oh
it's Leslie and [__] Paul Rudd are
having a debate I just saw that those
episodes this week it was hysterical man
[__] um Paul Rudd was really good
really funny though where he's doing Wii
bowling and then she's like why don't
you just bowl there and they cut wide
and there's like a bowling alley there
and he's like well this guy looks like
me
uh really [__] wonderful show man
like just and warm and sweet and like
very like Ted lasso
gives you the hardcore laughs and then
also gives you like some real heart to
it all throughout she's kind of like the
like the Auntie Michael uh Scott you
know what I'm saying like just really
like she holds that show together she's
absolutely [__] wonderful I always
loved her on Saturday Night Live but uh
what's her what's her name um Amy
Poehler Amy polar [__] she's like really
great in that show yeah I remember
listening to some interview with Mike
Shore who was talking about the network
he kept wanting to push the jokes on the
show right and he his whole thing was I
will make you laugh for 20 minutes out
of the show but you will give me four
minutes of those of the running time to
break a heart or two yeah and nobody
will care that they weren't laughing for
those four minutes if I make you feel so
100 agreed man 100 uh you know what I
just saw was the episode in season five
where they finally introduced Jerry's
wife and it's Christy Brinkley
that was [__] fantastic and there's
the episode and this is the weirdest
like it's a Parks and Rec cutter
remember that time on that show but
where Jerry went to the hospital because
he like had a fart attack
and the doctor just looks Dead part of
the camera says that man has the largest
penis I've ever seen in my life
yeah it's [__] good man if you
haven't seen it yet and I'm sure most
people like I saw it when it happened
dick but I didn't and [__] it's good man
you know what I'm watching speaking of a
thing that I should have seen much
earlier for a various number of reasons
I'm watching Atlanta for the first time
how is it I was always curious about
that show
um because I like him he's the white
people are like yeah it's like a black
guy finally came around
how how is it it's amazing is it really
good it's funny it's got Donald Glover
and it's got the other guy yeah
he Bates as well it's phenomenal I mean
all right so do you have anything more
to say other than this phenomenal uh no
you seemed like you had a thing you were
Black Mirror have you seen Black Mirror
because you said zazzy Bates I have not
seen the new shoes oh my God [__] I
watched this a couple weeks ago the new
season of Black Mirror which is only
like five or six episodes long is
[__] phenomenal and two of the
episode you know black mirror is always
like technologically Ben two of the
episodes are just flat out old school
horror like one is I don't want to spoil
it but one is like a monster thing and
the other is um
also a devil thing which was [__]
good man that guy was Charlie Booker
Brooker Brooker yeah oh my God [__]
if I could be anyone else as a writer it
would be that guy he's [__] talented
this show is so [__] good and you
know they were gone for like a red hot
minute like at one point he was like
during pandemic he was like why would I
even make a Black Mirror we're living in
it right now
um but man they came back strong it was
five or six episodes anybody know
six I think it's [__] worth your time
it's good I just showed my son the uh
the must be live Pig episode oh
one of the [__] most brilliant hours
of Television ever [__] made where
they're like this guy's gotta [__] a pig
or else somebody dies and
I I like it should be the model for
every TV show
right you gotta [__] a pig
so [__] you can't CJ but wait what is
Atlanta about
Atlanta begins as a story about
um Donald Glover's character Ern who
wants to be a music manager and his
cousin Paperboy played by Brian Tyree
Henry who's got a mixtape that's just
dropped and it's starting to get a
little bit of like local radio play and
he wants to be his manager and just help
him blow up his career
but it then becomes this kind of story
about you know initiative and capacity
and fame and race and class and gender
and parenting and crime is All Season
that's called Robin season and every
episode is about crime in some fashion
or another
um it's about yeah gentrification and
capitalization on black pain it's doing
all of these things while also being a
dense character study and really [__]
funny until it's not and then it's just
[__] weird
like there's a whole episode where and I
know like I I missed the the [__]
Atlanta Hive and the first go around so
I'm like everybody's seen Teddy Perkins
right
that was so [__] crazy I have nobody
to talk to about this it's because
everybody's seen it already looks like
you and Parks and Rec we're like hey
remember that [__] that's like eight
years old that's really good
let's talk about it because I can hold
you hostage on my podcast
um it's bananas he's basically playing
Michael Jackson
um in white face and makeup I've seen
pictures or yeah and it's the joke never
cracks they never let it slip it's just
this weird interaction with this weird
guy that Fame has Twisted and warped and
all the Keith Stanfield wants to do is
get a free piano and he almost gets shot
in the face
um beautiful what what our season are
you on episode are you up to um middle
of season three how many episodes how
many seasons they do four and that's
what they're on right now it's done yeah
[__] night all right I got something
to go to after yeah go do that I'm
waiting for reservation dogs to come
back which is maybe one of the best
shows on TV
you like it
dude it's really good so [__] good
funny or what season one is a little bit
more ramshackle where it says [__]
Knuckleheads in a reservation just
hanging out and doing weird [__] season
two becomes just like haunting and
evocative and still funny but it's it's
very much a show about teenagers on a
res that's informed by Death
like one of their best friends committed
suicide and they don't know why and that
just kind of colors everything but it's
all these characters and all these
stories and and imaginary like one dude
just keeps seeing a native Brave on a
horse who keeps making fart jokes and
[__] but it's
oh it's so good it's so good this is a
tiger y TV show Tak away TD and Sterling
harjo who's the showrunner head writer
[__] night man um no it's remarkable
another show worth watching I think it's
a no yeah man so I'm done with Parks and
Rec when I'm done with all the white
people I'll turn to the internet
Kevin you will never be done
especially now because I live in the
[__] Valley
oh yeah we got lots of white people out
here oh my God [__] throw a rock
um all right man so there we reviewed
some [__] uh time for the news time for
the news all right everybody Mark used
to [__] be a journalist and [__] and
then he's not but now he [__] does
the news
so give it up for Mark he's gonna do the
[__] News man
okay
uh we got more warm and fuzzy and [__]
I mean definitely warm yeah it's a lot
of liquor
um as with uh has been the last couple
of months the caveat of the news is
because of the alliance of motion
picture and television producers and
their inability and non-desire to
negotiate with the writer's Guild dicks
[__] there is not a ton of news
because they have nothing to put into
production they have nothing being
developed so there's no new
announcements of things so the news is a
little bit skin Flint
um these days but there is some [__]
that dropped two of these are entirely
about Deadpool yeah
oh my God I don't want to jinx it man
but this [__] Deadpool picture May
save the world
[__] I've seen some pictures and
heard some [__] you don't want to blow
it out of proportion no but [__] man
like it sounds like it's gonna be
[__] amazing did you hear
that they reached out to Affleck to
maybe play Daredevil in it
clearly they're doing the multi they're
gonna [__] like everyone's doing the
Multiverse they're they're doing the
Multiverse they're doing Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe yes
I just want to clarify for comicbook.com
and Tick Tock that Kevin Smith did not
say
that Ben Affleck is doing Daredevil I
read that did you hear meaning he saw it
on the internet the same place yes so if
your [__] Screen Rant
don't quote me because I'm quoting you
it's a vicious [__] Circle but yeah I
read online that [__] they that they
reached out to Apple or Affleck was
spotted on set and then yesterday or the
other day they said that Garner is
coming back as Elektra yep and then I
saw somebody wrote an article about like
or somebody tweeted and then somebody
wrote a whole article about this [__]
tweet because that's how [__] hungry
the news is lately that um oh man
they're just going after Nostalgia and
I'm like who the [__] is Nostalgia about
Jen Garner's Electra
maybe maybe even then and I remember
reading an article where she said that
she didn't like the lecture and I was
like join the club
um
so if it sounds like they're grabbing
all the [__] people that used to be
Marvel characters that weren't a part of
the Marvel Universe
and don't act shocked and uh you don't
like nothing shut the [__] up no but I
feel like the dude has been the model of
decorum and like you know what everybody
tried
but this sounds [__] good man this
movie sounds good as hell
um if that's what he's doing collecting
everybody that used to be a Marvel thing
that wasn't
the official Marvel Universe and killing
them off or even if he doesn't kill them
up I hear there's more than [__] uh
Wolverine in it more X-Men than than
human you're more X-Men than you could
shake a stick at I mean and again I read
this I didn't hear this from like
[__] inside sources I read this
online so if you're going to quote me
quote your [__] selves
um
it sounds like do you see did you say
James Marston I just did like and I he's
how do you hear that I just made it up
[Laughter]
but it seems as likely as anything else
that's right jury duty would be like I
will strap on the [__] visor again
I'm [__] here for it that sounds
wonderful where are they shooting this
[__] uh
uh England right England Canada
Vancouver in Vancouver
I mean I know they always shoot him in
Vancouver that's where the strip club is
Right orange orange peel or whatever the
[__] uh okay
the strip club from the first movie
what's it called orange something that's
a real strip club in Vancouver does Ryan
Reynolds own it no but but he's banned
City Reynolds right he's a Vancouver kid
and [__] so they just opened the entire
city to him oh God he owns that [__]
just not that strip but I think they're
shooting in England I've read something
that they're shooting in England I mean
they probably need for like the X
mansion I'm sure there's some like we
need an actual [__] Castle maybe you
got the internet over there JC five
orange is the what is it five orange
that's the name of the strip club five
orange or the Cobalt was used as the
exterior but it's five oranges I've
passed that strip club so I went to film
school in Vancouver so I passed that
strip club a lot what was your local
titty joint I mean I never went to it
and [__] right
[Music]
um so yes Deadpool uh three looks like
it's gonna be and they're shooting right
what happens if the strike happens they
have to stop or no I think that's why
they're shooting in England in case the
strike happens because then they don't
have to quit Too Legit to Quit right
because the wga has no jurisdiction
in England that's right we should all
move to England and make [__]
go over there and make clocks
that's what they call it over there
clocks clocks yeah with an a sure it's
not like solicitors
Proprietors Proprietors
um yeah man [__] did you see the
picture
throw up the picture Andrew look at that
[__] picture
oh my God man blue and yellow blue and
yellow blue and yellow blue and yellow
indeed he's finally wearing the colors
and a lot of people online are like what
he's got sleeves you I'll bet you a
billion dollars he rips those [__]
sleeves off at one point because Hugh
Jackman has these giant [__] guns you
don't hire you jack but you don't make
him work the [__] out like that and then
cover those [__] and sleeves sooner
or later he's gonna be like the [__]
gun shows in town sun's out guns out yes
um Ryan Reynolds one of the smartest
[__] in this business man he
listens to the audience he's giving
these [__] people what they want and
that's the blue and yellow suit how
[__] is that how long it's been 23
years
it's gonna be fantastic he'll probably
give him the headpiece too won't he
we'll probably see him in full mask for
the first time
this movie I'm telling you this movie's
Gonna Save the World man
and it's a third it's the third movie it
ain't even like Deadpool one [__] it's
three
prove it he's gonna stick The Landing
because then after that they're not
gonna make another one right they get it
right yeah oh [__] he's always gotten
that right those Deadpool movies are
[__] phenomenal
um yeah that picture lit up the internet
today
um I ain't gonna say it broke the
internet because that's old [__] no it's
like an Elon Musk look at it let's just
[__] look at it
look at that [__]
my God
and they just put that out there and
[__] they were like all right go ahead
look at it and [__] that's how confident
he is that's like Ryan Reynolds showing
you his [__]
and not just that he put it out in the
week that we've all adopted 19 new
social media platforms yeah and was like
this will pierce it it'll be fine oh my
God he's got a threads account and [__]
I don't I don't I can't keep up with it
man I just got too old
um you stopped Twitter I stopped Twitter
every time I try to [__] tag you and
like uh hey we're doing fat man be
honest as you can't tag Mark bernardo's
[__] you he's my friend I could do
whatever I want
that's how close we are
[Applause]
and yet somehow Elon Musk won't let me
tag you and [__] because I'm too busy
[__] his wife oh [__]
I'm not I wouldn't how many blue milks
did you have
I've been blue milking my whole life
um yeah you know what just [__] put
that picture back up
show that picture again Andrew make them
all warming look at that [__] man
God that's my [__] happy place that's
my happy place because visually it's
beautiful
um having you Jackman back is a
beautiful thing but it just shows you
that that [__] to the left in
the red absolutely cares man that's the
dude who's listening to the [__]
internet you know uh when I wish really
man give it up for him
when uh
when I when we watched Indiana Jones in
the Last Crusade my friend Ernie
O'Donnell he asked me with this
childlike innocence he was like doesn't
Hollywood ever ask the audience what
they want and I was like you poor
[__] uneducated fool
I was like no they just give the
audience what they think they want Ryan
Reynolds God bless his Canadian heart
literally probably read he's on the
internet all the time [__] probably
reads the internet and it's just like
why am I creating ideas I'm just going
to take the ideas that are given to me
for free and doing what we want man
[__] like he's manifesting literally
what we want God bless you so we've been
doing it wrong all these years yes
[__] [__] being original listen to
the audience and [__] if you're gonna
make [__] that's like meant for the
audience listen to the audience and
that's what he's doing he's giving us
those [__] blue and yellow colors God
bless that [__] rap scallion
all right what else you got
uh who's he married to
Blake Lively's [__] she's lucky man
could you imagine being married to a guy
because all that guy cares about he's
like what do you want
and she'll be like do this and he's like
I'll do it because that's what he does
he does what everybody wants he's
Canadian man he's a people pleaser
he's codependent is what he is
but I'm here for it God bless Ryan
Reynolds I will unhinge my jaw all night
long that's what I want [__] [__] you're
careful yeah sorry uh all right we have
one last news story what we just started
the news because you hit all of them in
one weird blue milk fueled Rampage true
I guess so I guess we did all the news
how did you see this picture oh also
Jennifer Garner that's true yeah well
Deadpool covered a lot of news it really
did yeah like most of the news uh
there's a there's an upcoming update for
Call of Duty which will introduce the
boys
as playable characters in Call Of Duty
Modern Warfare 2. the boys as in the TV
show as in homelander and black noir and
starlight and oh [__] do we have a
picture of that or no I don't know
standing by give it up for [__]
Andrew Man without him you ain't got no
[__] imagery
standing by
he's the unsung hero of this [__] he's
the Ryan Reynolds of this [__] [__]
he listens to the audience and he puts
up what they want although not right now
he's looking for a looking for a picture
We snuck this one on him it's coming
through now Khan oh [__] nice
oh [__] that was good that's deep
Cuts right there man just for you thank
you while we wait you want to hear a
cute story I would love to hear a cute
story give it up for bathman man
inventor of the blue milk cocktail God
bless his heart
so every year we take my daughter
Jocelyn to see John Williams at the
Hollywood Bowl did you go to that so we
went we went last night yeah and so
we've taken our kids one Harley wants as
well we uh so she we took her when she
was like 10 months old we took her when
she was like a year and a half she's two
and a half now so she kind of gets it
more
and so John Williams plays starts
Raiders March and we're in a box seat
and so there's like Jen and I are
sitting behind and Jocelyn's in her own
seat up you're in a box seat he's still
in a [__] bar isn't it rich man and
[__]
sir Johnson jumps up on the chair and
turns around and goes I know this song I
know it I listen to it at the bar
[Applause]
adorable and then dyfus took your child
away and then everybody around is like
the division of you why is his child in
a bar
how was the John Williams Show for those
that don't uh live out in California at
the Hollywood Bowl every year every year
yeah John what and I thought he stopped
this [__] isn't he like isn't he like
older than Sam Jackson he's yeah he's
91. he does 96 as I grade
how old is John Williams
he's 91. so do they begin every concert
with him going I'm 91 and everyone's
like wow
I mean I go every year because I'm like
he can't be doing this again next year
that's true I invented music
every year he gets my money because he
won't quit how long is the show so uh
usually like David Newman does the first
hour and then John Williams comes out
and does the second David Newman is who
of the Randy Newman the Newman dynasty
of Hollywood who's written everything
he's related to Dave Randy Newman yeah
Newman from Seinfeld
is he a composer and and you know yeah
um so he does a bunch of [__] and then
John Williams comes does he do John
Williams [__] or he does his own he
usually does like the music of the
movies and does like the best stuff
David Newman did Lawrence of Arabia
oh they perform and [__] yeah they do
like the best soundtracks and then they
build up they're like Now ladies and
gentlemen the [__] you've all
waited for jump out of money Fisto the
Ayatollah of rock and roller
John [__] 91 year old Williams will
he do it again next year let's [__]
see
Don't Clap too loud
so he comes out does he do this [__]
yeah he does he condone yeah I mean
that's how I make music they [__] say
uh as if like that's the thing that's
gonna break up all you gotta do this no
don't lift them very heavy but uh that's
what keeps him alive motility man doing
this [__] once a year but it's uh it's
pretty crazy he came out and he did all
of his hits
like E.T and
um Superman Billie Jean all of it
just so he did [__] ET uh put him on
the glass so E.T is
[__] I could do this [__]
and you could do this
and Superman is
too drunk
[Applause]
oh that must kill man that's when
[__] chicks take their tops off and
[__] like
yeah
what else does he do
and then does he do [__] and then he
did Schindler's List
I can't do that one
did he really [__] do shindlers
puts her tops back on it's like can I
have my bra I'm sorry sorry about that
put these away of respect how does that
go do Schindler's List
oh I don't I'm not gonna
that's like me going I ain't drunk
enough to do black stuff and whatnot
JC's like I am not touching Schindler's
List I gotta work my name is riefenberg
I am not touching Schindler's List
um does he do he must does he close with
Star Wars or open with Star Wars he did
a Star Wars in the middle what and then
he does an encore and The Encore was
like more [__] Star Wars he did Yoda
and
um he ends with Imperial March that's
how you end
yeah and he did it he conducted it with
like a lightsaber and do they show clips
from the movie as well for some of the
movies they do but not sure
why am I sad
ler's list
pull out your hankies it's Schindler's
List and they run [__] out with your
cops out it's sad
[Laughter]
um so some of them they do clips for not
everything yeah sometimes you just watch
the [__] they have to license them so
they're probably like what's the cheap
this guy they make this 91 year old [__]
likes and [__]
he don't get carte blanche and whatnot I
I mean that's probably why they had Star
Wars clips they better [__] give him
[__] for free and whatnot it better be
all free clips and [__] for the rest
of his life
[__] gave us so much [__]
music it's like there's two composers in
the world him and Danny Elfman like
those are the two rock star composers I
ain't saying like there ain't a billion
great composers but like those are the
two composers everybody can do their
songs like what the [__] did I do
all right but do it do a Honda you know
you know who's did all the John
John Zimmer
that ain't [__] hanza cartoon man
or something like that but you could do
John Williams you could do Danny Elfin
Dan elephant's done
[Music]
damn
this is the one can't do with Spider-Man
though can you do Danny Elfman Spiderman
no
I mean Spiderman inarguably one of the
biggest [__] franchises ever but can
you do Danny elfin's theme to Spider-Man
I can't
but you could do like this is Halloween
this is Halloween
pumpkins John Williams he ain't got any
lyrics does he
he don't come out all shirtless and
[__] ripped like Danny Elfman and do
a set and [__] like that does he so I
just listened to my buddy does a podcast
on the music of uh called soundtrack
show
and he the love theme of Superman
actually had lyrics that he wrote yeah
can you read my mind and they recorded
it yeah recorded it and but in the movie
they they were like voiceover she wasn't
great so they used her they just had to
speak can you read my mind there's
there's yeah very much but there is an
actual recording where the chick is like
can you read my mind like she's really
it's like a pop yeah I was supposed to
be like a pop song once in a while you
hear it on like a Sirius fxm like
[__] 70 show or something like that
so John Williams has been nominated I
just did this on my trivia a couple
weeks ago he'd been nominated for God
like
some ridiculous amount of Academy with
48 or how many has he won
uh I don't remember but three of them
were for best original song
and one of us can you read my mind I
don't think that I don't think that was
one of them what were the original songs
eight mile
[Laughter]
I can't even do the lyrics and [__]
um has he really look it up you got the
[__] internet there
how many
53 nominations five wins what the [__]
kind of odds are those Susan Lucci [__]
right there yeah really man no wonder
I'm never going to win Academy Award and
[__] I mean that and quality
hey [__] bartender this blue milk
ain't gonna milk itself
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go home and [__] the [__] out
of my wife
[Applause]
I'm taking my shirt off for the first
time in 30 years
put on Little Prince Blue Light
yes turn on your blue light yes
everything's all right I turned the
lights off that's the only way that [__]
happens oh so okay best song nice to be
around from Cinderella Liberty in 1974
which who knows and then that was before
you were even born thank you oh [__]
give it up for the bartender everybody
this Show sponsored by the bartender I
need a straw thank you where's my straw
where's my [__] straw
thank you
uh all right so that was 74. what else
if we were in love from yes Giorgio in
1983 the [__] is that I have no idea
this is what he wins for these were
nominations nominations for songs okay
and then his other song nomination was
Somewhere In My Memory from Home Alone
that's kind of like the there's lyrics
to the to the score
John Williams did Home Alone
he's basically done everything so yeah
you didn't do [__] Batman [__]
because if he did he would have been
like dead
you know what Danny Hoffman also did he
never gets enough credit for this the
score to Scrooged amazing [__] score
[Applause]
oh my God we were mixing and scratching
doing a [__] medley right there we
could do the Hollywood Bowl [__] John
Williams I mean when John Williams
decides not to like they'd be a [__]
not to call screen rant's gonna be like
Kevin Smith says [__] John Williams
hahaha
that [__] better
uh what else what did he win for
uh he won his first one for Fiddler on
the Roof in 1972
Jaws Star Wars Fiddler on the Roof but I
mean that was a play first right
Broadway play musical best scoring
adaptation in original song score
interesting all right then what and then
he got uh he won for Jaws [__] he won
for Jaws well that makes sense did he do
Jaws at the at the Hollywood Bowl
no are you [__] me
somebody wants their money back yeah no
kidding man could you imagine having a
career so [__] storied that you're
like I'm gonna skip Jaws tonight
because I got a zillion other [__]
pieces to do I mean he did Harry Potter
he didn't play Harry Potter the other
night did he do the Harry Potter score
and he didn't play it [__] good I'm
William too many bangers and truly man
he did uh so Star Wars PT course
uh these are the ones he won Schindler's
List those are his wins respect and then
I could read his nominations but we'll
be here for an hour I mean we don't have
any more news yeah [__] him feel free
we're just killing we're all the ones
that he can say yeah we're all drunk so
go ahead 76 he was nominated for Jaws
then Star Wars and close encounters and
he didn't win for Star Wars he won he
won nominated and one but he was
nominated for Close Encounters the same
year are you [__] me
and close encounters is all about music
you know Steven Spielberg was like [__]
this [__]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm gonna make it through like two notes
somebody killed Kevin well no I uh every
time I'm in New York and I'm walking on
the streets I have to do the Otis theme
I got your paper
[Laughter]
that is that's a [__] Banger too man
[__] this guy's good
here's my hot take Tom Williams is good
what else JC uh then
81 Empire Strikes Back oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
just like the show's dead the show
jumped the shark tonight
uh 82 Raiders of the Lost Ark I mean
[Music]
that's 82 yeah cause that was 81 when it
came out and then
uh
Return of the Jedi
did what was the was there what was the
new part of Return of the Jedi
yup yup like he did that [__] did he do
Yum Yum Yum yeah
Jabba's theme the tuba
wow wow
that's my best java is that what I look
like doing it right it's great it's the
best part of the night wow
I didn't know there was a job as theme I
mean I'm sure I knew that but I'm not
familiar with it
and then uh India is there a salacious
crumb theme there should be there better
be bib Fortuna's theme there was Lappy
Knack which was done [__] he did that
[__]
his son wrote that
jet
no John Williams's son jet
I'm gonna double down he's also got a
kid named Jen
um who also is the lead singer of the
band Toto
what's up
John Williams's son sang I Bless The
Rains Down in Africa
gonna take some time to do the things
never
had
to do
[Applause]
turns out I can talk about black stuff I
sang Africa
[Applause]
the whitest [__] song on the planet
that's a song that they make fun of in
Book of Mormon when they sing I am
Africa it's pretty much making fun of
that song is it that or is it also the
do they know it's Christmas
yeah hey yeah no there's Christians in
Africa guys
missionaries for thousands of years do
they know it's Christmas they also have
[__] television
and there won't be snow in Africa this
Christmas except Kilimanjaro has snow
all the [__] time
like the most basic looking effect
song ever
listen to these hot takes man we're
coming at [__] Live Aid like [__]
workout later coming for your [__]
is he dead I'm sorry no he's still
around isn't he Bob yelled off I don't
know Bob Geldof still alive now I'm
coming for your [__] y'all though
he's alive he just Don't Like Mondays
thank you thank you well done
what else you got what other movies can
we sing loudly
I mean after that run he did Empire of
the Sun The Witches of Eastwick oh
Empire of the Sun I don't know that
[__] song at all I don't know that
music at all which is these book had a
pretty banging score but I can't sing it
which is Facebook is an amazing movie
because you get to see Jack Nicholson be
the Joker years before he plays the
Joker
women a mistake or did he do it to us on
purpose because I wanna know stop sorry
stop
nope this is not the one I guess I guess
you're right it's bridge too far what
else you got uh born on the 4th of July
worked with Oliver Stone
that's not Tom Cruise I'll give you a
thousand dollars if you could do the
score for [__] born on the fourth of
July
sounded way too perky for born on the
fourth of July I don't know if you ever
saw that movie but it's kind of sad
that's when they take his legs off
[Laughter]
Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade that's
just more of the same keep going oh it's
got that great Grail theme what's the
Grail theme do it I oh my God I'll let
Andrew do it
man
uh but just a little bit bigger yes
um home alone I can't [__] it over here
I don't even know it but but AI is a
Banger's list which we've already
established we're not going to touch
yeah uh Amistad
nope
they played it they played that last
night did they yeah they played Amistad
yeah they don't play Jaws but they
played almost they did before
they did it before John Williams came
out before it came out yeah give us
those Free Birds he's like you do that
[__] before I get out there man let
David Newman do that [__]
uh Saving Private Ryan I'm skipping some
but what was Saving Private Ryan's theme
like born on the fourth of July probably
yeah
uh Harry Potter Catch Me If You Can
which was awesome Catch Me If You Can
it's [__] great man it's very Jazzy
and I'm not like a jazz guy but that's a
good score
uh Memoirs of a game what is Harry
Potter's theme how's that [__] go
yeah
[Music]
something like that yeah it's very
Christmassy
[Music]
exactly
sure they're doing a TV show oh Jurassic
Park that's right he wasn't nominated
for Jurassic Park [__]
how's Jurassic Park go again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
how does Jurassic Park go
we're making dinosaurs we're making a
stegosaurus
foreign
that's one take we're done
press that [__] Barry Gordy
going on the road
parks and wreck and I said to my wife
about Rashida Jones I was like you know
where her parents are
and she's like everybody knows who her
parents are I was like [__] tell me
she's like Quincy Jones and Peggy Lipton
I was like all right well who's Peggy
Lipton she was like she was in Twin
Peaks I was like and she was like Mod
Squad I was like you're all right
so I [__] with you you're pretty good
yeah
after like 25 years I finally approved
my wife I was like you're all right man
you knows you've been paying attention
uh Tin Tin War Horse oh [__] Book Thief
I'll give you a thousand dollars if you
could do the theme to 10 10. I'll give
you a thousand dollars if you saw Tintin
anybody in this room see Tintin but yeah
I saw it you [__] Liars you're all a
bunch of liars
as a little white boy on a bicycle yeah
did you see Tintin I did see Tintin why
because it's a little white boy and a
bicycle
I see all the little white boy on
bicycle movies
it's my favorite kind of movie I know
why I suddenly turned into Charlie
Murphy
I see also white boys on bicycle movies
the late great Charlie Murphy give it up
for Charlie Murphy
you could tell a story man
[Applause]
it's 10 o'clock yeah I guess we should
move on
oh
yes oh there it is hey give it up for
Andrew man he got the [__] video game
image Call of Duty the boys
uh yeah I'll be honest with you that was
kind of weak give it up for [__]
Andrew man
he sits in that [__] hot back room
and he works hard for you
this is the part of the show where I
start yelling at the audience long
enough to Google Images yeah it took him
a minute though
you're [__] slipping Andrew
don't let's get you slipping
um all right yeah we should move on to q
a uh or you could just read more movies
I was having a good ass time trying to
remember themes and [__]
made me happy that I remember as many as
I did like it's kind of like if you were
somebody held a gun to you and they're
like do [__] Raiders
I'm I'm or do [__] John Williams I'm
all I'm pretty good all the way to
Schindler's List and then I'm like you
might as well pull that [__] trigger
man so I don't remember how that [__]
goes
there's a Yiddish unit Maybe
I'm trying to remember I can't remember
what are we giving away today oh well
[__] [__]
uh our good friend Brett deakin probably
came through again man as he always does
he did he's in the house tonight give it
up for Brett Dakin where is he
okay yeah
[Applause]
I love Deacon so I mean I'm drunk so I
love everybody I love digging so much I
named a movie character after him if you
ever saw Zach and Mary Make a Porno the
character of Deacon that Jeff Anderson
plays named after Brad taken
uh once again uh our friend our great
friend Brett deakin he works for the
good Folks at 40x as far as I'm
concerned he is 40x and [__] uh he's
giving away some 40x tickets man so when
you win whoever [__] uh gets the
question picked by Banff man they're
gonna walk away with two tickets to go
see a 40x picture man this is not quite
the summer to go see a 40x movie
although it's Mission Impossible
unfortunate oh yeah [__] is it oh you
reckon my balls son that's right man you
could take these 40x tickets go see
Mission Impossible the movie that's
gonna save the box office of the summer
you know I used to have an opinion as a
moviegoer and [__] but now I have
opinion as an exhibitor somebody who
owns a movie theater so we have three
[__] movies that were pinning all our
hopes to man you are right there holy
[__] okay I heard that [__] [__]
uh Oppenheimer Barbie and [__] uh
mission impossible so Mission Impossible
dead reckoning it's up to Tom Cruise to
Save Summer [__] 2023's box office so
you could go see [__] for Mission
Impossible in 40x is Oppenheimer gonna
be in 4dx no oh come on [__] good
thing right
what about Barbie are they doing 40x no
so Mission Impossible is your [__]
way to go man uh 40x if you've never
been on a 40x [__] experience you sit
in a chair that literally just [__]
brings the movie to life and [__] I we
went and saw Guardians of the Galaxy
were you there I was not there for that
we saw uh
uh far no way home we did see nowhere
and we saw Dune there as well I saw a
[__] Guardians of the Galaxy in 40x
and no [__] I ain't even [__]
exaggerating at one point the chair
shook me almost out of the chair
uh the chair comes to life it moves with
the movie and [__] it shoots water at
you smoke happens and whatnot it's
[__] a crazy experience uh it makes a
movie [__] better so 40x even if you
don't win these tickets tonight there's
a 40x theater somewhere near you in some
big city how many 40x theaters are there
today Brett
50 plus 40x theaters across this great
[__] nation of ours make sure before
you leave this best of all possible
world you go see a [__] movie in 40x
it's a hell of an experience so uh
winning questions are going to win uh
240x tickets and what is this
trade paperbacks this is a member of our
audience has donated three of his you
hold it up in your shot since they cut
to you and [__] so three of his
trade paperbacks and it's called
Immortal era whose is this
what's your name captain
give it up for Ed Davis man
Ed Davis ain't just [__] talking to
talk he's walking the walk he made a
goddamn comic book and this is a thick
ass comic book thick as a dick tell us
about it man what is it how about up
yeah jump up there give it up red Davis
man
he's gonna testify
all right so this book I actually came
on your show back in 2019 when I had
just one issue out and before the
pandemic
good old days is it hard to sell books
when the pandemic was going on but I had
one out you guys gave away some stickers
for it and now I'm about to release the
eighth issue of the series [__] hey
give it up for me self-publishing
he's making comic books
so the basic premise of the story is
it's a world 200 years in the future
where everyone has stopped dying so
everyone's become immortal but no one
has powers and abilities so it's a it's
two groups fighting against each other
one who wants to keep the status quo and
the other who wants to save Humanity by
killing them
the way everybody lives forever but you
can be killed you can you can't be
killed they want to find a way to kill
people because in this world you could
become a decapitated head and still live
on people are still aging they can still
have a disease that'll just last
infinitely so there's a group of
Fighters who realize that that's not an
existence they want so they're out
trying to make the world a better place
by killing people it's legit captivating
idea give it up for that [__] all right
Ed that's some good [__] well done Ed
you the writer I'm the writer of the
series yeah who's your artist my artist
is Cesar Oliveira he's based in Brazil
[__] hey look at you man [__]
giving jobs to non-americans well done
I employ some Americans as well
um so what this is compiles how many
issues this has six issues inside of it
six issues all right so the winning uh
folks who uh JCS their Banff man asked
their question gonna get 240x tickets
and they're gonna get the immortal era
trade paperback is this available in
comic book stores around the world there
are many comic book stores that have it
mostly around Los Angeles better be a
few in [__] Brazil I'll tell you that
right now spew in Brazil good and right
now we're gonna about to launch a
Kickstarter next month for issue eight
[__] hey man give it up for him he's
making his dreams come true well done Ed
thank you my friend well first we'll do
this and then we'll do this thank you
[__] out look at that [__] man
Ed's better than us
making his own books I had to turn to
Dark Horse to make a comic book and [__]
well done all right Banff man you pick
out some questions all right I do I
didn't realize that we were all drinking
tonight so I picked some sentimental
ones so maybe it will oh my God don't
make me [__] cry yeah we're gonna
wind up crying and [__] the internet's
gonna come for me whenever I cry they're
like you [__] [__]
first question uh Ruth Ramirez
come on get up here bro
[Applause]
[Music]
what you watch you watch you what you
got assume the position Ruth and ask us
your [__] question
for the microphone if your first time
here I'll let me coach you I'm asking me
off my boyfriend because we're like
whenever he's gonna get it what's your
boyfriend's name Matthew give me another
[__] Matthew man
[Applause]
yeah look at that [__] his birthday
today so oh happy birthday Matthew happy
birthday Matthew give it up for Matthew
it's his birthday
you know that [__] getting blown
tonight well done he's already wearing a
tiara yeah he is already in the chair
all right Ruth use your mouth for
something else
what's something that you've picked up
from the younger generation that's
helped you
helped her growth as a creator also
what's a piece of advice that you have
seen that be Universal
and that it's worked for you and it's
working for younger creators all right
well dude it's it's a two-parter and I'm
drunk so do it again what's the first
part third part what have we picked up
from the younger generation what have we
picked up from the younger generation
fair enough and then the second part
um
what's the piece of advice that you've
seen that's worked for you but also for
younger creators for other careers
what's a piece of advice that I've
that's worked for me and other creators
all right [__] what have we learned
and what are we passing on can we let's
just do one there's so many
there's only two all right you go first
so copy you what have I learned from the
younger generation yeah
yeah [__] hey you're not kidding
about that yeah like stretch
limber up a little bit
uh no I mean I think that it's it's the
it's the job of a younger generation to
remind the older generation to take
chances you know because I think the
older you get the less likely or
inclined you are to do a new thing
because you've been doing an old thing
for a long time you've gotten good at a
thing and so you kind of lean back on
experience you lean back on on on time
you lean back on on the miles that
you've driven but kids are not afraid
you know like
kids will jump off [__] Cliffs kids
will do the dumbest [__] because they
think they're Invincible even though
they're not really and even creatively
they don't know enough not to do the
dumb things and that's how they learn to
be their own person and so I think the
longer you do any business the longer
you chase any creative thing it's
remembering to take chances remembering
to walk off the cliff remembering that
it's not the end of the world if you
[__] up in fact you'll probably find
your way to the best thing as long as
you're willing to [__] up a little bit
so I think it's that the fearlessness of
Youth is a thing that that and all the
generation could hold on to and take
some Spirit from
um in terms of advice that I've been
given that I think applies and I do pass
on when I can
it's
um do the work it's expect nothing know
your worth be humble but let
[__] know
it's yeah it's I saw that on a t-shirt
once yeah put that out on t-shirt one
time but it's it's just like you're not
gonna get it because you think you
should have it you know you have to earn
it so do the work if you want to be a
writer right if you want to be an artist
draw if you want to be a photographer
shoot do the thing and then if you can
continue to do the thing you'll get good
at it you'll get your ten thousand hours
in then you'll be in a professional at
it and if you can put in that time if
you can do that work when nobody is
watching when somebody's ready to look
you'll be ready
I haven't learned anything from The
Young Generation man I just I made the
last movie I made was clerks [__]
three so
I can't think anything that I've learned
from young people you know my kid
well
I don't know I want to like credit my
kid with like
something but
Papa yeah I I just I don't know I I
think I'm usually kind of telling her
stuff and whatnot
um yeah no I like his answer let's stick
with his
real quick though uh I I went to go see
once upon a time in Hollywood at the new
Bev recently and I remember I saw Harley
and I remember your story about how and
when she didn't think she would get the
part she wrote out a character thing or
Tarantino and that's what basically
helped get her the rules so I don't know
maybe if you can grab something from
that or if you did grab something from
that there you go obviously
yeah he remembers something about my kid
I didn't yeah that's right
my kid [__] did the work whatever the
[__] but uh
oh it's a blue milk come down like she's
a good kid uh whatever the [__] she did
it I'm trying I don't know if I should
tell this story because I don't want to
like embarrass her and [__] but
there's uh all right [__] it
um
this is what I learned from my kid my uh
so the next movie We're making the 4 30
movie is uh kind of based on my youth
um and the main character is kind of
based on me in the same way that Dante
was kind of based on me in in clerks but
Dante and most of the movies I make
take place firmly ensconced in the 90s
forward uh the next movie We're making
the 4 30 movie takes place in 1986 so I
go further back to an Era of my life
that was different and [__] and so
uh Austin Zager who is in clerks three
played blockchain Coltrane
um Harley he was in when we did the Sun
and lockdown thing for TBS on the series
what was it called celebrity show-off
he played the main character and stuff
so I love Austin and I was like hey man
let's why don't you play
the main character in 4 30 movie so
essentially he's playing a young version
of me
since he's dating Harley I was like oh
[__] you should play the girl that he's
in love with and whatnot
and so you be in the flick as uh he's
playing a character named Brian David
who was that was the original name that
my parents wanted to give me and then uh
some kid was born in this Hospital like
two days before me who was also named
Brian David and my mom had to Pivot and
she went with Kevin Patrick instead and
my grandmother was like who the [__]
Kevin Patrick the mailman like what the
[__] because everyone in our family is
named after some [__] who came before
them like my brother's named after my
dad my brother recently said
my God I'm so drunk my brother recently
said now I'm going deep cuts my mom was
in the hospital for like 11 weeks and
[__] my mom almost died she recovered
she's home she's doing well and [__] so
yeah
yeah so my brother you know when my mom
was like at her worst and when the
doctor was like you might need to look
in the hospice care you know I was I did
the [__] moment where I was like oh
my God I haven't been as good a son
as I should have been and like you know
I said my brother lives down in Florida
like right across the street from my mom
I was like you're the best son and like
I wish I'd been more like you all this
time as I've spent the last 30 years of
my head up my own ass and stuff like
that and my brother was like look let's
be honest mom loves you best almost like
the Smothers Brothers and [__]
um he goes mom loves you but I said
that's not true he goes no that is
[__] patently true number one you
remind her of dad and that like really
[__] touched me and stuff I was like
oh my God you're right I do and he goes
uh number two
um you have afforded her
the ability to do things she never would
have done in this lifetime had you not
become Kevin Smith and whatnot because
my mother as much as I love being Kevin
Smith my mother loves being the mother
of Kevin Smith if you've ever gone to
like one of my events and she's there
she [__] like [__] soaks up she's
like you know I [__] pushed him out
of my [__] right right
That's My Boy and [__] so she loves that
[__] and also just whatever like a the
job has afforded me the opportunity to
afford her things that she never would
have done in this lifetime and [__] so
he's like you got that but he said but
most importantly you're the only one she
got to name it's like he's my brother's
named after my dad and after my some
uncles and [__] my sister is named after
my aunt but I was named after nobody
there ain't no Kevin's in my family no
Patrick's whatsoever and my mom picked
that [__] name when she had the pivot
and [__] so he's like so she loves you
for that you're very much hers because
she got to [__] you're her creation
from the jump and the fact that you went
on to become you and [__] just reflects
so well on her and she loves that [__]
so I was like you're right I am the
favorite
I am the goodest boy
my brother's watching the show going
what a dick
um so anyway so the character is named
Brian David because this is his
alternate version of me like this is
what would have happened if I didn't be
me and stuff like that so Austin's
playing this character Brian David and
then you know there's a girl that he
likes and her name is Melody Barnegat
and stuff and so I said to Harley I was
like well you play Melody because like
you're [__] dating Austin that makes
sense and like you guys act together
that'll be cute and [__] and then
recently recently like [__] two days
ago my kid was like look I just this is
the hardest decision I ever had to make
but I don't think I should play that
part
and I was like why and she was like
because I think it'll be weird if I play
the girl that you fall in love with
and I hadn't thought of it like that you
know I just thought of it as like oh
you're one of my favorite actors and
[__] like that but instead she saw it a
little deeper and I was like oh I guess
you're right so I guess the next
Generation thinks about [__] more than
than I do
or at least she does or something so
there there's a Harley story for you I'm
gonna get yelled at when I get home
yeah
she'll be in the movie but she won't be
that part give it up first you want a
[__] book and tickets
well done
can I can can I play the girl that
Austin falls in love with yeah why
aren't you doing [__] and drag that
would be amazing
hey we've been doing casting and like
you know I don't know normally when I
write a thing I just write it for people
I know right that's why I always see the
same [__] people and [__] that I do
um and we've been casting the [__] out
of this next thing and I've got some
cool people whose work I love that I'm
gonna get to work with for the first
time but there's kids in it like when I
say kids I mean like youngsters and [__]
like people who are in their 20s but
playing in their teens and stuff like
[__] Beverly Hills 90210 style I'm 43
years old yes
so we um you know uh like had to go
through something I haven't done since
really since Mall Rats where Amy Ryan is
our casting uh is it Amy Ryan well Amy
yeah I think it's amyron is our casting
director and she has been sending me
tapes self tapes of people auditioning
for the movie and it's people I've never
seen before a whole young crop of
[__] actors and it's crazy because
again I haven't done this [__] since
Mall Rats Mall Rats was the last time
where somebody sent in or what they
didn't send in I sat down with all of
young Hollywood and we were casting Mall
Rats it was people like [__]
like uh who's the [__] well Ben
Affleck obviously the people who are
casting Mall Rats but who are the people
that didn't get cast [__] uh
what's her [__] uh you know
you know Sweet Home Alabama
spoon yeah she was one [__] you know
[__] there's a bunch of famous people
who are super famous now who came
Jennifer Aniston for Mall Rats
she did she come in no Bradley pitford
no he was already [__] famous Bradley
Whitford no
um but we saw a lot of young Hollywood
who grew up to be old [__] Martin
Sheen Martin [__] Sheen but now I'm
seeing all of current young Hollywood
um which is interesting which is nice
and um
so we'll be casting a wide net for that
as for that part as well anyway I'm
rambling at this point over to you bam
you know what's handy tell me I'm not in
the Screen Actors Guild
are you not I'm not so why because
you've never given me lines
you've been Kevin Smith
you've been in I've been in two
you've been in two but you've never had
a line I've never had a line all right
well maybe this time we'll give you a
line no you won't
well we can we can Taft tartley you Taft
tartley is when you bring somebody in
who's not in Sag but you could let him
say a thing once and they don't have to
join sag but the next time they say a
thing in a in a thing then they have to
join seg they're a must join so we could
Taft tartley who give you a line you get
one line yeah oh the pressure
can you handle it duck [__]
how'd you know the line
uh over to you bamf man [__] I'm drunk
uh Tim Tim Doherty
give it up for Tim
my [__] Tim Doherty
Tim [__] dirty go Tim go thank
you spell that last name go ahead it's
d-a-u-g-h-e-r-t-y I was literally gonna
guess that it's got a little bit of the
Irish in itself
and a variety of other things but my
question to both of you is what was
something you're in your line of work
that completely surprised you just out
of the blue something you weren't
expecting something you learned or
some surprised you about your line of
work it's a good [__] question give
it up for Tim man
thank you
something in my line of work that
surprised me I got a lot of lines of
work man so let me pick one
um let me see
I'll pick directing
what surprised me about directing
um here it didn't well all right this
surprised me
one time I was interviewing Martha
Coolidge
who directed A most she directed a lot
of movies including Real Genius which is
an amazing movie with [__] Val Kilmer
she directed rambling rose with Laura
Dern but the film she directed which
made the biggest impact on my life is a
movie with Nick Cage and Deborah Foreman
called Valley Girl an amazing [__]
movie from the 80s
part of the reason that I live in Los
Angeles man and now live literally in
the valley because she romanticized both
Hollywood and the valley you know when I
was a kid I lived in Jersey and all I
knew about California or this area of
California the Southland if you will was
what I saw in movies and TV and
particularly
the valley was romanticized for me by
valley girl and by Bad News Bears Bad
News Bears took place in the North
Valley and stuff so Martha Coolidge to
me one of the greatest [__] directors
ever lived
I interviewed Martha Coolidge
uh for a podcast series I was doing
years ago at Lincoln Center in New York
and it was called smuviola it was when I
was deep into podcasting and stuff long
before everyone else jumped in the pool
and so we did a screening of Buckaroo
Bonsai and I interviewed [__] Peter
Weller who I recently ran into at
another Comic-Con I think a Dallas
wonderful [__] guy that's where I'm
from yeah yeah
um and John Lithgow was there for that
and then we did uh valley girl and it
was with Freddie Elms who was the DP and
[__]
um Deborah Foreman who played Julie and
uh and Martha Coolidge who directed it
and Martha Coolidge said
that the phone stopped ringing for her a
certain point
and that's why she stopped erecting and
that blew my [__] mind I was like
what do you mean and she was like I hit
a certain age and people stopped calling
me that [__] terrified the [__] out
of me wow where I was like what do you
mean like [__] you hit a certain age
and they don't give a [__] anymore and
this is somebody who directed what I
considered those three movies alone
which are back to back to back man
[__] she had to run a valley girl
Real Genius and rambling Rose and
rambling Rose like I think Lauren was
nominated for a [__] Academy Award
maybe if I remember correctly at least
she was nominated for off Academy Awards
like critics best and [__] like that but
I think she got nominated for Academy
Award maybe a Golden Globe whatever the
[__]
and I was like what the [__] you direct
those three movies and people stop
calling
and she said yeah and that [__]
scared me man where I was like oh my God
[__] they can not call you one day
and then I remembered like oh [__] like
I'm an indie artist like when I started
I didn't start with a studio I didn't
start because somebody was like we're
gonna let you [__] direct I started
because I was like I want to direct and
so from that moment forward and this is
going back 10 maybe 15 years I made sure
that I kept so many irons in the fire
that nobody was ever gonna not [__]
call me if they didn't not call me it
wouldn't [__] matter because I can
make my own [__] bed I don't need
somebody to be like we're gonna let you
direct I'm like [__] you I will let
myself [__] direct absolutely hearing
that Martha Coolidge wasn't getting
called to direct really [__] changed
me as a filmmaker in some way so there
that's the thing
[Applause]
you
uh it's hard to pick one as a director
because all of it surprised me because
the one thing I directed was the first
thing that I directed so it's all like
why the [__] is this blue milk empty
Loki let's [__] go
more wine smash
um but in in comic books
there's there's this amazing moment when
you write your script
and you have the ideas what that script
is and depending on how descriptive a
writer you are in comics you could be
Stan Lee and just be like hey Jack we're
gonna blow up a building in this one and
maybe they're [__] I don't know the
it's going to be weird somebody's gonna
have some marital issues and the kid's
gonna turn into a puppy go and then
everything's a surprise for sure but if
you write your script kind of deeply
you've described characters you've
described places you've given you know
context and and and Contours to it all
but there's always the moment when the
artist when you get pages in from the
artist and suddenly it's real suddenly
what had just been words is not pictures
and there's a moment on the door in the
distance when you know gravity novel
that I did a couple
oh yes that one
a couple years back that I've been
working on for a very long time put it
together for a door in the distance
um so I've been working on that book
before it was released for about 10
years maybe longer than that
and
I I guess in describing the main
character I just described the kind of
girl she was sure 10 years old she's
precocious she's adventurous she's
unafraid of anything but she's sweet and
hard the world loves her you know and
the the she is the light in the darkness
for everybody who ever meets you and
that's about it and so Ariella Krista
and Tina who's my artist and I might
have told the story before so where is
she from she's from Jakarta Indonesia
and uh and so she read the script and
she started giving me sketches for what
the characters were and the first
sketches of Adora were of a little black
girl
and that was never in the script sure
some of that is because I guess I had
been gaslighting myself for a long time
that most of the characters that I were
writing began as white people and I
would consciously shift them into black
people because sure that's the world
right like as as a person of color
coming to Hollywood coming to Comics
coming to Media the images you are
bombarded with are not of yourself
so you somewhat subconsciously began to
refocus who gets to be the heroes of
your story they rarely look like you
and so I didn't even put it on the page
that she was a black girl it wasn't in
my head that it was and ariella's
drawings were all of her with like curly
long hair and and brown skin and white
eyes and I was like why I never asked
for this she's like well it's based on
your kid of course she's black I was
like [__] that was the biggest surprise
I'd ever gotten because I'd never asked
for it I didn't know enough to ask for
it but she penetrated all of the levels
I guess maybe growing up in Indonesia
she's not as
bombarded with America As Americans are
and so she doesn't have those layers and
levels of of unlearning to do and she
saw it immediately for what it should
have been and delivered unto me what I
always should have asked for awesome and
so that was the biggest surprise I think
I'd ever had in the thing that I helped
to make thank you thank you what a
[__] answer give it up for that
thank you Mark
congratulations man you win some tickets
and the [__] book The Immortal era
well done excellent question give it up
from ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
I have an answer for that one too which
was pre-scumin villainy yeah I thought
that people went out to bars to get
drunk or to
and I was like I do now too as well but
owning the bar and spending time here is
what you realize is it's the same reason
like people go to Comic-Con for the same
reason uh and it's like not celebrity
autographs or this thing or that thing
it's community
and that really surprised me going from
like working behind the camera and film
to like being in a space with people is
that people come here for Community they
come to fat man beyond for Community
they come discovering for Community they
come to their local bar for Community
um
it's like a better version of church
[__] A yes
[Music]
and it
to be fair it costs about as much as
church
that's true but the drinks are stronger
yeah way stronger and [__] and they
don't guilt you out with like this is
the blood of Christ they're like this is
a blue milk and you're like [__] yeah
I'll take nine here it's like this is
the blood of dragons yes
the blood of Buddy Christ that's true
that's why I come though I come to the
FI I'm coming to the scum of villain and
get drunk although I will from now on
I come for the community I love when we
come to this show you know I like when
we do it at home and [__] because it's
convenient but I like coming here
because it's a sense of community I'm
surrounded by a bunch of like-minded
individuals that if they drop the
[__] bomb today
which is something we don't think about
anymore but in the 80s that's all we
thought about and [__] Chris Nolan
thinks about it a lot yeah no [__] he's
counting on it and [__]
um I'm surrounded by a bunch of
like-minded individuals a bunch of
people that feel and think like me and
that way is not exclusionary it's
inclusionary you know this place is all
about [__] acceptance and like we all
[__] adhere to the same things man
like we all believe in a bunch of
[__] ain't real which is kind of
like the Catholic church and uh
and I don't know I [__] I really
respect that I like to imagine the bomb
dropping and we're all stuck in here and
we're like hey does anybody know how to
make like a solar panel no but I know a
lot about Blake seven
does that help
deep cut well done
all right last question in the evening
is uh from Juan Carlos alcantar get up
here Juan
why
[Applause]
how can I thanks well my question could
that mic right in your [__] face like
you're sucking a dick
there you go yeah so my question to you
guys both is uh first of all I'm a big
fan of you guys so I just want you guys
know thank you came all the way to San
Diego to just come and see the show
we'll be there in a week
[Laughter]
well my my question is to both of you is
uh you know let's say what if Andy
muschietti came in came up to you guys
to approach flash director Andy machete
flash director and he said you know what
guys I heard your podcast I'm a big you
know I'm in trouble I don't know what to
do
I need you guys to help me uh re
recreate this universe that I don't know
what to do with what would you guys do
differently with the Batman and Batman
and Robin and the Brave and the bolt
because he's making the Brave and Bold
next reportedly
um what would I do I mean honestly like
I'm telling you I watched The Flash four
times I thought that dude did a great
job I loved I saw it mine it's wonderful
I know a lot of people are [__] on
it and [__] but I enjoyed the I'm
including this [__] guy
um what but anybody who brings back
Michael Keaton is Batman and lets him be
the Michael Keaton Batman he didn't
change him he didn't direct him to be
anything else [__] literally at
one point was like how much do you weigh
like [__] took me right back to 1989.
that dude needs no advice from me uh the
one thing I would say though is like you
might want to stay away from Ezra Miller
um
seems to have hurt his cause a little
bit but other than that he seems like a
really good director like the flash is a
[__] entertaining movie I know the
internet [__] on the CG but
I don't need my CG to look [__]
convincing like it's a story about a boy
who solves all his problems by running
super [__] fast so you're already
taking a leap anyway and stuff so I
wouldn't tell him to like do better CG
unless it's like you want to [__]
avoid getting [__] on by the internet
maybe get some better CG but not for me
I I don't know I think the dude's a hell
of a director he needs no advice from me
you
all right nine pieces of advice
no I'll say I'll say two things one is
hey we don't need an origin story for
anybody so stop yeah [__] you better
not show us pearls ever again no I don't
want to see no [__] pearls falling
and [__] like I get it as mom got killed
move on we know
um but to drill down on the father-son
relationship like I think that when
these movies work they work because
they're emotional they work because they
they're about characters going through a
thing in their lives who happen to be
superheroes not necessarily just
superheroes
um and then
[__] it you don't need an expensive
Batman movie you never have needed an
expensive Batman movie no it's a dude in
the [__] costume themselves crimes
yeah he drives a car that maybe you have
to build maybe you don't yeah like you
don't need a third act with a flood I'll
tell you that much no no and you never
have no like it's you can make a 40
million dollar Batman movie [__]
preach [__] go say that [__] again
there is I mean John Wick is the best
Batman movie we've ever had yeah just
[__] do that [__]
you know and so like do Reacher he's
Batman without a mask yeah like we if we
understand now what Batman is we don't
need spectacle with Batman we need
commitment we need will and those things
on screen are not expensive
um and so that way you don't have to
make 300 million dollars to get to make
your next one you just got to make a bit
to make a bit more and so like
lower your like slow your role on just
spending the the things spend less good
maybe some advice right there man like
flash costs what 200 plus 250 some odd
million dollars and that's why they're
like it's never going to make its money
back it's one of the most [__] money
losing superhero movies ever made you
can make Brave and Bold for [__] 50
million and for and clean the [__] up at
the box office by making it for Less yes
excellent people like you won't make
more money because it's more expensive
exactly because it's [__] Batman
we'll go anyway
oh my Lord
[__] truth
um that's it that's all I got remember
it's a father-son story and it's a
[__] up family and just lean into that
and save some money also don't do Damien
Wayne well I mean I think
no but they're doing why not because I
want to see Dick Grayson I want to see
Dick Grayson on the big screen done
right
with all due respect to Chris O'Donnell
I don't want a 90 year old [__] Bruce
you know Dick Grayson I got your credit
card give me a kid like [__] what's
his name [__] Grant Morrison one of
our best and brightest on an early ass
episode I talked about this before on an
early ass episode of uh Fat Man on
Batman
I was interviewing him and I was making
some jokes some [__] low-hanging
fruit jokes about [__] Batman and
Robin and their [__] relationship
and he [__] put me on on pause man it
put me on notice he was like don't do
that he's like don't he's going to
Batman and Robin relationship is so
beautiful he's like because
it's a story of the man who looks at the
boy and sees the childhood that he never
had and the boy that looks at the man
and sees the person he wants to be
so it's like give me that man give me
give me that give me a young boy Robin
and [__] and which sounds dirtier than I
meant it sounds dirty coming out but I
don't mean it like that man I mean does
it sound as dirty going in yeah [__]
[Music]
give me that pure relationship right
there think about every Dick Grayson
we've ever seen like [__] Bert Ward
was like 80 years old and [__] and
[__] Chris O'Donnell was 90 years old
give us a kid [__] kid who
watches his parents [__] die and
that's what Bruce sees in him he's like
I saw my parents die when I was that age
here's my chance to [__] minister to
this child I've been where he is and
[__] so I hope Raven bold is a kid Robin
because that's what she like [__]
think about it like look at this room do
you see any kids here yes it's a bar but
I mean if you do take them home yeah get
them out of here
but like kids like I got into this [__]
when I was a child you know what I'm
saying like I watch [__] Batman and
Robin or Batman you know Bruce Adam West
Batman when I was a [__] kid and [__]
and the in the comics they included
Robin the character find of 19 whatever
the [__] because it was meant
to speak to a child who was reading a
comic book and reading stories about
grown-ups doing these astounding Feats
and here was somebody that mirrored them
who they were a youngster and [__] like
I get it we're all old and we're into
this [__] and it keeps us eternally
young but like we gotta feed the Next
Generation man and the next generation
is [__] young so make that Robin a
little [__] boy man 9 10 11 years old
I know there's all sorts of weird
[__] [__] about like why would you
bring a child into this [__] world
but the only one who gets away with that
is the boy who the man who was a child
when the same [__] happened to him Bruce
Wayne understands why you would [__]
okay a child to duck bullets and [__]
like that makes sense to me so make him
a kid that would be my advice to Andy
muschetti make Robin a kid Tom Holland
has a younger brother right yes yes just
get some young [__] kid you know who
did it real well tell me Indiana Jones
in Short Round [__] yes absolutely
right man and where was he in the recent
[__] don't get me started but [__]
yes yeah Indiana Jones and short round
did that [__] right you know what who
else did it right
uh [__] uh hit girl like in uh kick
ass
it's [__] fantastic you know adult
child relationship and training a kid to
be a [__] you know superhero
essentially I mean she was kind of
badass though um but still Robin should
be [__] badass this is a child this
is literally what did they call him in
[__] in uh Dark Knight Returns like
[__] you know Bruce says like they
called you the boy
not the Boy Wonder but the boy Target or
whatever the [__] like [__] it the idea
that this little kid is somebody that
every [__] like gangster and super
villain is like oh my God I'm gonna
[__] kill this child that's so [__]
up
do that you know what I'm saying like
[__] because what kid couldn't handle
that nowadays maybe like in the 70s and
the 80s be tough to handle but kids look
at porn nowadays on [__] PornHub you
can see a [__] child put in danger
and [__] and be like yes and Bruce Wayne
should be no you're fine
I'm being honest
you can [__] see like Bruce Wayne
should be a little [__] up right like
because he's he was [__] up himself as
a child to watch his parents get killed
so he should be an adult who's like you
know what this kid can handle it because
I was that kid once and I [__]
handled look at me I'm [__] alive and
[__] like that so put this 10 year old
in danger show him the right porn send
them out to fight
but it's also good motivation for Batman
right I mean how many times have we seen
a Batman movie where he's like
still angry about that [__] that
happened when I was a kid yeah wouldn't
it be nice if his motivation was like
I'm not gonna let you
kill this kid I'm not gonna let you hurt
this kid [__] it that's beautiful right
there let JC write that text me
or you're absolutely right
it's like hey you know it'd be awesome
for you kid I don't know trauma therapy
like maybe let's get you the help I
never got because Alfred's a really bad
character and don't do that that would
be my advice too don't [__] apply
current psychology to characters that
were created 50 60 years ago you know
what I'm saying like there's a reason
these characters have transcended
[__] time don't be ironic and be like
this [__] relationship is
codependent just make it as simple as
like this [__] man was a boy once and
he watched his parents get killed and it
[__] him up for life and [__] so he
got his hands on another child and he's
gonna [__] him up too because he doesn't
want to be lonely I guess when you say
it out loud it is kind of [__] up well
but do that man don't [__] make it
make sense this [__] should not make
sense like at the end of the day you get
a zillion [__] programs about true
crime and [__] that makes sense sense
this is fantasy it's about a
[__] puts on a mask and a cape
to fight [__] crazy ass villains and
[__] don't give me reality that's what
bugs me about the Matt Reeves thing
ma'am where it's like I'm gonna make
this [__] as real as possible don't
don't make it real then it [__] falls
apart if you want to make it real make
it reach her that's better and [__] if
you're gonna make it Batman make it
unrealistic because this [__] would
never happen in the real world I know a
lot of people like Batman's more
realistic than Superman they're both
[__] stupid man like
this [__] makes sense Kevin Smith
they're both stupid none of it makes
sense
Screen Rant has their next [__]
headline and [__]
I called them out recently on Twitter I
[__] listed a bunch of these
[__] that like [__] take
articles from this show everyone
liberally takes from this [__] show
so I was like look man in a world where
you take [__] like [__] I say and
turn it into [__] articles click bait
do me a favor advertise my shows it's
mod Castle
and only one of them did Man superhero
hype give it up for superhero hype
they literally were like they they
advertised this show they were like
[__] Kevin and Mark are doing fat man
beyond and we sold this show out and
[__] and I think that had something to
do with superhero hype the rest of them
including [__] Screen Rant didn't
[__] do a goddamn thing so I'm just
drunk enough to say a [__] Screen
Rant get with the program you're gonna
take from me you gotta give back give it
up for [__] giving back
thank you one another question excellent
question give it up for Juan man
[Applause]
[Music]
well done
um are we finished that's a show
have we finished setting my career on
fire yeah
I don't give a [__] anymore I got blue
milk that's all I need this episode's
brought to you by Blue milk ladies yeah
[__] hey thank God we didn't have a
sponsor they'd be like we're quitting
this show
uh ladies and gentlemen if you're ever
in Hollywood and you come this coming
villainy Cantina make sure you get
yourself some blue [__] milk
Chase it with water I had at least five
of these and I feel [__] amazing man
uh Joe have a good time tonight
foreign
honestly when we came tonight I was like
I don't really have anything to talk
about boy we [__] how long we've been
doing this [__]
we did a lot of things
really singing when you do a score right
it's like what do you call that [__] I
don't know I don't know what karaoke
yeah I did a lot of yelling tonight it
was like [__] screen ran how long
we've been doing it two and a half two
and a half hours man yeah we got no news
we got no up front we saw a show we
didn't really care for two and a half
hours later that's the miracle of fat
man beyond man [__] we can spin straw
into gold
if that's what we're calling it that's
what we did it's truly that
um I know I just said it but I'm gonna
do it again y'all have a good time
tonight
as you can tell I cannot self-validate I
need your validation to make me feel
good
um we can't have a single [__] show
if we didn't have a place to do it give
it up for JC and the scum the villain
and cantina Batman
and give it up to the most thoughtful
[__] in this business the only
[__] writer behind this bar Mark
[__] Bernardin
and that ladies and gentlemen at home
and here at the scum and villainy
Cantina in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard is fat man beyond for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernardin
I'm sorry Babble the [__] off I was
gonna say Babble the [__] off wrong show
tune in next time same fat Time same fat
channel uh smodcast.com or youtube.com
Jeff's kiss [__]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome
as a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
easy